Get ry four,
three,
two.
Who won?
Ah,
and what lively's gentlemen,
let's go champ.
Shout out to Shannon,
the Canon Briggs.
Shout out to the flat earth.
Shout out to young Jamie for being a
newfound believer and
it shut off
to chill on Dudley.
I'm handing it back,
but my brother,
thanks for coming with me man.
We have fun.
We just got back from a wild pig hunt,
ladies and gentlemen.
So if you're a super not into killing
animals is super not into eating animals
or hearing people talk about eating
animals,
now's definitely the time to shut this
one off.
I get it.
We'll talk about,
I'm sure we'll talk about fitness or
something good about food for sure.
Our tree life beverages.
Um,
yeah,
health.
I ate nothing but garbage over the last
two days.
Just straight.
Great and good food too.
Like uh,
they,
they cook good for us there but I corn,
no,
not corn flakes.
Raisin brand.
So sugary was little delicious dude.
You murdered later.
I thought it was in like,
I dunno,
I thought I was in a,
in a frat house there.
The way you're going through raisin
brand and Fritos and I'm a mess.
You know I didn't have to feed us,
but I had a lay's potato chips,
like potato chips.
I did knock down,
I knocked down a pack of m cool ranch
Doritos.
They weren't how I remembered him when I
was when I was like 11 and those came
out.
They were the greatest thing of all
time.
They were,
I don't know,
something happened to them.
You know what I think as you get older,
when you're a young kid and you eat
something terrible for you,
like a Ding Dong or ring ding,
you know those things they see,
they feel so good when you're eating
them.
They feel so good.
Like the idea that you could just take
that white plastic wrap or rip it open
and that chocolate delicious hockey puck
with the cream inside of it was there.
Oh,
you didn't give a fuck about your house.
You're like,
I'm going to eat this thing right now,
and he gets so excited.
But as you get older,
and we talked about that this weekend
used,
you kind of recognize what's happening
when you do something more like you're
more in tune with like what nutrients
you're putting in your body and what,
what their effect has on you.
Oh yeah.
Big Time.
And you start to,
it's funny how your taste buds change.
I recently started liking onions and
didn't and mushrooms and they were the
only two things I did not like it all.
You remember when you were asking me
about the morels and you couldn't
believe that I didn't like Morel
Mushrooms.
I actually had some mushrooms in a,
um,
some type of an oriental dish.
And also I'm like,
what the heck it tasted for the first
time when I tasted a mushroom,
it didn't just tastes like mush.
It literally had a flavor.
So I've included them on my meals,
like if I'm at a steak restaurant or
something and I genuinely are liking the
taste of mushrooms now.
Weird.
Like your tastebud shifted.
I think it happens all the time.
Or boy,
Harry,
he just also now know or started really
liking green peppers.
Whoa.
Yeah,
no where it's a mystery.
It is a mystery.
He said,
I,
if I've always wondered like what?
When people enjoy something that's
really strange,
like in Iceland,
they have this really bizarre pickled
shark that is supposed to be atrocious
for everybody,
but people from Iceland it,
well,
it sounds like pickled herring.
Every something way more intense.
It's supposed to be like really intense
like shark.
It's like a fermented,
see if you could find it,
Jamie.
It's supposed to be levels,
right?
Gusting.
I mean,
what do you think when you hear blood
pudding,
you intro,
I'm out.
See,
and there's people,
I've got friends in England that love,
they love blood pudding.
Well,
they're in the sausages,
you know,
like blood sausages.
I've had that.
They love it though.
We have our own dean on eating Icelandic
delicacy,
fermented shark.
Never forget an Anthony Bourdain had,
if he had to go there to try that.
If he says never again,
never again did.
It's interesting because people have
shifted how they feel about sharks.
Yeah,
I have as well.
I've had Maaco,
but people have shifted how they feel
about it.
What is this right up there with
airplane food in Nambia and ward hog
rectum according to CPS.
He's hilarious.
That's so funny man.
What have weird things.
So they figured out some way to make
shark tastes just disgusting and they
like it.
They really enjoy it and if they want to
claim it will give them that.
I know,
but what the fuck is going on in their
head?
Like did,
I just would,
um,
I would love to see,
look we can assume that you taste things
the same way.
I taste things that can't be the case
cause I like things that people hate.
Like I like certain hot foods that some
people just despise.
Like how the fuck do I know what they're
experiencing?
That's very weird.
One time Sharon and I were out to
Fuddrucker's the hamburger place and her
mom was there and uh,
we were doing the machine and Sharon's
like she was putting in like the cherry
part of Cherry coke cause you select
your flavor.
So right.
The chair,
she literally made this cherry coke and
her and her mom's like,
what was that?
And she goes,
Cherry coke.
You never had cherry coach like Oh my
God,
that's disgusting.
While she says that she didn't have her
glasses on,
she literally pushes cherry coke and it
and she filled her cup with cherry coke.
So Sharon,
I kind of just looked at each other and
did this.
We went back and sat down and she was
like,
she went through her coke like that and
so she was just staring.
She didn't know it was cherry coke.
No,
when we were doing it she asked because
she saw the red but when she did it,
yeah she didn't have her glasses.
She selected that one.
Anyway.
So yeah about halfway through the meal
she's like,
oh isn't that coke just so good here
cause she's from England and we said
yeah it was cherry but she was totally
stand off because she couldn't mentally
put together cherry and coke cause she
had never tried it.
Maybe that's what it is.
When people say,
oh I hate venison.
Have they ever really had venison or at
least venison worthy eating?
Most people probably haven't.
It's,
I think it's probably really hard to get
someone to do it.
Right.
It's not commercially available.
It's probably,
um,
people have done it poorly and then you
get that weird,
I'm like a prejudice that a lot of
people have of it being Gamey,
right.
Quote Unquote Gaming.
Yup.
So untrue.
We uh,
we have uh,
a big yeti out in the back of the
vehicle loaded with very fresh organic
swine.
Yeah.
Wild pigs.
Pigs are,
it's a,
one of the weird ones that people,
some people are going to get upset if
you have anything,
but if you want wild pigs.
Why?
Like I have a very good friend who's a,
an agent.
It's a very nice person.
And uh,
we were talking about hunting things.
She goes to do you hunt pigs,
you can hunt.
Pigs are ugly and she loves animals.
She loves them.
But her immediate response was like,
fuck those pigs.
It's weird.
Like that animal gets no,
it's,
it's so invasive that,
and people recognize it for some reason.
Like the way you look at it.
I don't want it to say that I don't have
love for them.
I think it was cool even looking at him
and we saw a lot of cool.
They're brilliant too.
It's fascinating.
I mean I was amazed at how smart they
were.
It's fascinating that,
did you send him that picture?
I put that on instagram.
Oh yeah.
That's awesome.
I didn't even see that.
I didn't have my cell phone didn't work
out there.
So this uh,
this is actually a female pig that you
and Steve stocked in on.
I was filming right where I'm standing
and you guys got so close and you could
hear baby,
you could hear piglets kind of
squeaking.
So you actually didn't you stand up with
your camera and take a picture of the
nest
and everything?
Yeah I did.
And it stood up like 13 or 14 feet in
front of us.
It was so close.
It was really close.
So it was like,
whoa.
You kept,
you're cool.
Most people would,
would lose it right there.
Cause they,
I mean,
you know the damage for those of you who
don't list or who are listening and
don't know,
uh,
wild boars,
extremely dangerous if they want to be
their cutters on their bottom teeth
cause they,
they pop their teeth and when they do
it,
they actually file that noise,
is them filing their cutters.
And have you ever felt the inside of a
big doors cutter?
I mean it's literally like a knife,
you know,
and they,
when they come by,
I mean one little hit on the inside of
your leg and that's fatal potentially.
It's
a beast of an animal.
They're enormous.
What's really crazy is that they were
brought here.
A lot of it was by that William Randolph
hearst guy,
that
Kooky bastard that was so crazy.
The William Randolph hearst guy who was
the guy that citizen Kane is kind of
based on,
right?
Orson welles masterpiece.
Citizen Kane was based on this crazy guy
who also coincidentally a as the guy who
campaigned to make weed illegal.
He was the guy that owned hearst
publications.
And so he,
uh,
he had this idea in his head,
this is the story,
was that hemp,
they're starting to make paper out of
hemp.
And he was threatened and there was like
a popular science magazine and said,
hemp,
the new billion dollar corn crop because
he owned like these fields of hemp,
or excuse me,
these fields of trees they used to make
paper out of,
he owned paper mills and he own
newspaper.
So apparently his fear was in converting
everything to paper.
He would lose millions of dollars on all
his traditional trees that the user
paper.
So he started printing stories about
marijuana being this terrible thing and
that Mexicans and black men are raping
white women.
And people went,
what the fuck is this plot?
We've got to stop this right now.
And so they made the prohibition on
marijuana and it happened directly as a
result.
That's the conspiracy theory of him
wanting to stop a competitor in the
paper business.
So it's so hilarious.
This one crazy fuck also brought over
punch a wild boars and just let them run
loose so he could shoot them.
Yeah,
that will now Texas is,
well the most of the south central us is
just overrun with them.
People
both don't know.
And it's like a giant rat.
It's like it,
I mean,
I'm not probing,
there's nothing wrong with like,
we have like category categories and
categorizations of animals and like
nobody minds if you kill a bug,
but you get to a certain size thing like
people rat traps,
okay,
you gotta do what you gotta do.
You get bigger than a rat.
And people go,
Hey,
what the fuck are you doing?
Right.
And there's something weird.
You,
you get to like pigs and people go,
why are you killing pigs
honey?
What you said about coming into hunting,
what their acceptance level was and it
seems like for sure things that we
perceive as like ugly pigs,
like Turkeys look that way.
Um,
you know,
their heads are kind of,
they don't look that cool when you look
at them up close.
They've had good color.
But anyway,
it seems like Turkeys and pigs and even
if you,
if you both fish,
those are like entry level.
I'm shooting something that people,
that's kind of the segue is turkeys or
hogs.
Sharon.
Um,
my wife is from England,
had never hunted.
My boy had never hunted.
Their family,
had never been around hunting.
So when they came here it was a whole
new perspective of how many wild animals
are in you.
No one in society.
We almost hit several with our car when
we lived in Wisconsin and then they just
started,
you know,
they would just destroy any hopes of a
garden that we would have.
So Sharon started going out and filming
me on some hunts and one time we were on
a hunt,
Illinois and this dough comes running in
her tongue's hanging out.
Three bucks come behind her and these
books are like,
she's literally trapped between three
bucks and she's,
you know,
she's just wanting to get away or
tongues hanging out.
She's not ready yet,
but there's three horny bucks there and
she's just sitting there.
It's obvious they had been running most
of the day.
And then two bucks started fighting.
One buck came in,
kind of,
you know,
ended up kind of scooting her with his
horns.
And then they were just running her
Ragen and Sharon's like,
is that what the ruts like?
And I go,
yeah,
the males literally just run the females
until they're like,
have no choice but I have to breed right
now.
And then it happens.
And then they're like onto the next
lady.
So she pleases,
she says when she watched it,
she said,
so she goes,
if I were to get into deer hunting,
cause at that time the only thing she
had shot was a Turkey and then she
hunted,
um,
a wild hog and she goes,
so if I go hunting for deer and I
decided to do it,
she goes,
I would only want a buck.
And I said,
all right.
You know,
I was,
I was glad she had an open mind to it.
And she's like,
I feel like I'd be helping helping a
sister out.
She kind of said it a funny way.
She goes,
she goes,
that is like your friend at the bar.
And she went up to get two of you
drinks.
And now there's three dudes that like,
well I'm not leave you alone and you
like can't get back to your normal life.
And she's like,
I feel like it'd be helping a sister
out.
And I'm like,
Yep,
that's what you'd be doing.
I don't think people who live in cities
have any idea of how many deer there are
now.
If they went through Iowa,
like people went through your,
your area,
they would be like,
what the fuck?
It's like every,
every mile or so.
You're seeing these packs of deer?
Well,
how many just ones did you see on the
side of the road that people would
struck?
Yeah,
quite a few.
You know,
and not,
not everyone is,
is uh,
lucky enough to just,
um,
hit a deer and that's it.
And you go to,
you go to the repair shop and they fix
your bumper.
Did I ever tell you about my dad?
No,
I didn't.
My Dad spent many years going through
orthodontics cause he always wanted
perfect teeth,
but he never had like the right type of
what you did tell me this never had the
right type of like insurance.
And stuff to do it.
So finally we get later in life.
He's in his right,
I think he went,
started braces when he was like 35 and
he finished it like 40.
Wore the retainer for two years,
like everything.
Next thing you know,
he's driving down the road and he had a
Honda civic driving down the road.
A buck runs out in front of the road,
he hits it,
the body of the deer comes through the
windshield into the passenger seat.
The horns came in and hit him right in
the teeth.
So he's got like,
I don't know if it's too,
every now and then he'll snag in front
of me and pull,
pull the ones out.
But yeah,
it was,
it was like,
it was the worst thing because all he
ever wanted was perfect teeth.
And like,
as soon as he had them right there in
his hand,
this crazy buck decides to commit
suicide and jumped through the window of
his Honda.
But the reality is that,
I mean,
that's what it's like.
I forget the numbers I was working on,
uh,
a book to try to,
um,
introduce some people in Europe to bow
hunting.
Um,
I wasn't trying to get it necessarily
legalized.
I was just trying to give information on
why hunting in the u s is something that
people at least need to keep an open
mind to and why it's necessary.
And I was trying to write a book and
granted,
um,
for those of you who are listening who
aren't familiar with Joe and I release
our relationship,
um,
I shot competitively for a long time a
shot with the u s archery team.
I did a lot,
a lot of miles throughout all of Europe.
So a lot of my friends were really
sensitive to the fact that I was also a
hunter.
And then obviously,
um,
I met my wife on a plane to France,
her all of our family,
there's obviously from Europe.
So this is a subject to where I've tried
to,
you know,
explain it the way that I'm explaining
this now and you know there's,
there's such a difference between areas
that really need that as part of,
I mean it is population control.
Look at how many we were gone.
We were probably hunting what,
16 full hours and how many hogs do you
think we saw including the little ones,
which will all be breeding within six
months.
Right?
Every baby we saw right now can be
breeding in six months.
Is that right?
Yeah,
six months.
So I mean you think you'd do it twice a
year,
right?
So we saw at least that will,
that we saw that one sow that you
stocked on.
She had maybe eight right little guys.
And then when we went out at dark that
time,
how many ton of,
oh my gosh.
Let's just say we saw 30 total at least.
So within 60 days,
any of those six months,
any of those females will be able to
breed and then they're having six to
eight to 10 again,
animal man,
it's a weird animal.
It doesn't seem like it belongs there.
It's really strange like because,
because it's an invasive species,
you see how it's unbalanced.
They just make babies and go and make
babies and go and you've got a Whoa,
they got to like the [inaudible] ranch
keeps a wrap on it.
But some places where they get away from
like a ranch environment,
which is kind of ironic
because like in,
in some places like San Jose,
which have never had a problem with
wildlife at all,
other than the occasional deer,
they're getting wild pigs and once they
get in,
man,
whew,
you've got giant fucking
animals.
I mean they're,
it's a totally different kind of,
it's not like a squirrel to his big ass
animal.
It's running around eating people's
yards.
Well,
when they were brought here,
people had them on their farm to have a
continual replenishment of food.
It's not like they were growing them to
say we want to have this massive pig
farm.
They were growing them is that pigs were
great because you could eat on them
continually throughout the,
throughout the whole year.
Right.
And they continually reproduce.
But once they go out into the wild and
there isn't a family that's utilizing
that,
you know,
small batch of hogs or chickens or
whatever it is,
then they just go crazy.
Yeah.
Really crazy.
I mean,
what a,
what a bizarre animal to invade into an
ecosystem pig.
They're just so powerful.
Like we,
we look at them in a weird way.
He know they have like that bad
reputation because uh,
you know,
when,
when when someone calls someone a pig,
like if you call person a pig,
it's like one of the worst things you
can say to a person out of it that way.
I mean,
if you call someone a monkey dussel's
Yep.
I'm the fucking dumb monkey.
That's me.
I'd say that.
You know,
if you called some someone at Gazelle,
they'd be psyched.
Right?
Dude,
you are a gazelle.
They'd be like,
yeah.
You think?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You're an animal that gets jacked by
lions.
Could I be,
what's my animal?
We're going to Avatar.
What's my,
you'd probably be some sort of primates
from a large primate,
like maybe an orangutan.
Something along those lines.
Really.
Did you ever see that movie,
which was the stupid movie where I'm
overweight.
They kind of just sit there.
It's one of my favorite kettle bells
that Orangutang.
Yeah,
I love that guy.
He's got to get it really good.
Yeah,
he does.
It seems like it'll all the primates.
That's the one that would fuck with you
the least.
Be like,
what's up dude?
How you doing?
I guess if I was the big guy that was
actually just kinda soft.
Which one would freak out the most of
primates?
Well,
I was going to give you a silver back,
but now that you say that,
I would say if I had to fear one thing
of the primates,
I don't know.
It could be like a freaking,
if baboons are bigger,
they could be pretty.
I mean if a Babin brain and temperament
was in a silver back
would be a monster.
Oh,
we had this discussion if like some of
these animals that are just,
this is what's weird.
People think we don't like animals
because we shoot him.
We actually appreciate him more.
Like,
I really think about,
I have so much respect for grizzlies,
you know,
in brown bears and then I see something
like a silver back and the strength of
those things.
And I think if,
if this was a society where everything
like fought for its turf and those two
met,
I mean,
yeah.
So
you think,
well,
what's interesting is I think he's
still,
there used to be bigger and bigger
animals than them.
I'm talking died off.
Yeah.
Well we can relate to you.
The dinosaur thing would've been,
that would've been so cool.
What if you could short face bear?
You ever hear about that thing?
Ah,
I have machine.
That short face bear was enormous.
Bear that lived in North America has
apparently was fucking huge.
Bigger than a polar bear.
Ferocious Predator,
died out somewhere around,
I think they think 10,000 plus years
ago.
Well it ain't shit.
You know,
that's,
that's not that long ago.
Am I right about that?
Or is it a hundred thousand years?
Might be a hundred thousand years.
How big will find out when that thing?
Yeah,
it was enormous.
Enormous bear.
But did they know it was the face?
Yeah.
No,
it's the bones.
it's the skull.
It had a totally different face.
That's the size of it.
Is that amazing?
So would they not know that was a polar
bear?
Well,
short face bear has a different skull.
That's what it looks like right up
there.
But it was bigger than a polar bear is
like the biggest bear ever by far.
They were fucking huge.
But that's my point.
He's like,
shit can just keep getting bigger and
bigger.
It competes.
And then look at people.
People are bigger now than they've ever
been before.
Thriller.
Throw a line main on that sucker.
Do have something that,
look at that.
That looks like the Predator.
Look at the face on that thing.
It's an enormous,
super bare.
That's right out of the Avatar.
Fuck that.
So the idea was it's a bad wolf.
Did they have like a wolf?
We haven't heard of her wolves,
weren't they the biggest,
that thing,
that short face bear.
Um,
there's this guy named Dan Flores and he
believes that that short face bear and
the [inaudible],
apparently a bunch of other people that
studied the migration of people into
North America,
they believe that Short,
that short face bear might have been one
of the barriers and it was so ferocious
and so fierce.
Could you love matching?
If you were a dude and his family and
you're walking from Asia to the United
States and you see one of those mother
fucker of motherfucker bears,
he'd be like,
what in the fuck am I doing here?
An enormous,
that's what you're saying for the,
for the border,
that's what we need everywhere.
Cages for Kiki kicked ourselves.
Guard.
The board is with giant Wolf dogs.
Oh my gosh.
That thing,
it's so much bigger than a polar boy
vampire or Werewolf.
It's always an underworld was a good
call.
Vampires,
vampires,
24,
seven c Werewolf's have to become
Werewolf's and then they have to go
back.
Leaves you vulnerable.
So many jacks you when you're not aware
of wolf,
it's like you're a bully for a couple of
nights out of the month and the rest of
the month your pussy.
Yeah.
Right.
I mean that's really what the Werewolf
is.
There's a lot of people like that
and a werewolf.
It would be a really weird one if it was
real humanity.
If we had to like find out who the
Werewolf's swear and you have to make an
ethical choice to kill him when he was a
person or do you uh,
do you lock them up for a couple of days
a year cause it's done.
It's fall.
I Dunno.
A vampire
would be pretty cool.
I guess they say that mathematically
it's not impossible.
It's not possible.
If Vampire's couldn't exist cause
there'd be no people left,
but there's certain amount of time
there'd be no people.
Well that's,
that's a very logical way to put it.
Yeah,
it makes a ton of sense because you
would infect someone,
see you and I would like someone else.
You and I would like it because the
older we get,
the more we really realize what makes us
happy and what we like to do.
So imagine if right now you knew,
dude,
I'm not,
I'm 50 but who cares?
Who Cares?
I know exactly what I want to do.
We could all be like a thousand and Jay
are still happening because you're just
endless now.
You know what I mean?
I definitely don't know what you mean.
I lost you somewhere in the middle of
that.
No,
you were just saying mathematically for
years and they live.
I'm just saying if for you and I we
enjoy our life.
For some people that I know that don't
enjoy their life,
that would be a nightmare.
The fact that they had to keep going and
keep going,
that'd be pretty pumped.
I think the thing about vampires,
they wouldn't work as mathematically.
If you're a vampire and you by Jamie,
Jamie becomes a van par and he bites
somebody else and you have to buy it
like a person a day.
Whereas the Werewolf,
it's only a couple of nights a week
where you're an asshole.
Like if there was like a cage and you're
like,
I feel it coming on.
It's like,
you know,
if a woman was like,
oh my God,
I know my period is coming,
the guy would be like,
we're getting really close to the full
moon.
I'm going to go check myself.
Then he checked yourself in one of those
big ass steel cages and then you turn
into a werewolf or a couple of days he
chill out.
You could maybe if you don't like if
you,
you locked up in a cage,
like it was like fasting and then when
you're fasting your body sort of starts
burning fat.
You lose your appetite,
you calm everything down.
Maybe that's what it's doing.
I've been doing with werewolves,
I've been doing that.
Not to change subject.
We can,
we can talk wearables more.
Um,
pull up the Irish elk,
Jamie that,
remember when I told you about that
thing?
That thing's cool too.
I wish that was back would.
That's a crazy looking at,
I mean the short face bear fuck that
short fixed.
Yeah,
but things scares the shit out of me
that thinks scares the shit out of me.
I don't think people understand how big
it is.
It's so much bigger than a polar bear.
It's essentially a real monster,
a real live monster,
and it was most likely,
ferociously carnivorous.
Would you if that is,
if that thing was still alive right now,
now out in random parts of the
wilderness,
would you hunt or the Irish shock if it
was viable population?
Talking about the short face bear.
No,
I wouldn't be in the book.
We've talked about,
fuck you man.
I have a hard enough time with wild
pigs,
dude.
I'm freaking out.
What are you doing?
Working out?
No Way.
I'm just thinking if I was,
if I was a kid,
you guys,
you went through the woods.
If I was a kid and I went through the
woods with my buddies and we accounted a
short face bear and eight,
one of my friends just right in front of
you,
you'd be like,
that's a monster.
Yeah,
well it would be for sure.
I'm just saying,
I know that when you and I talked about
Hawaii,
I said I would love to learn to surf
from Shane Dorian.
And you say,
I'm not surfing because of the sharks.
So monster soup,
it's the same.
It is the same.
They can go fuck themselves.
So people are crazy.
All you people so you wouldn't hunt if
they're short faced bears.
I'm bound freaking out by pigs,
man.
How close we got to those pigs.
Some rogue experience follower that's a
genetic specialist is probably going to
construct one of those suckers just so
you don't hunt anymore.
I don't think it'll work that way if
that's the,
they're really wasting their energy if
they put it towards that.
There's certain animals though that that
have to freak you out.
You have to respect them.
You know,
we were talking about all the different
encounters that people have had where
they were bluff charged by grizzlies.
Oh yeah,
we're talking about that this weekend.
Yup.
And Steve Rinella,
my good friend and the host of the
amazing podcast,
meat eater and television show meat
eater was uh,
they were on this hunt and they got
charged by these grizzlies.
It's a mama bear and her cubs and it's a
full on charge and this thing is big.
I mean,
I don't know how big is a 400,
500 pounds and they're bigger than that.
How big was shit?
Was it a brown bear or a grizzly?
Grizzly in like math,
Finland?
Yeah.
It could have been 600 maybe.
Whatever it was.
It was so big.
It was so big and it was covering ground
so fast.
Yeah.
Like when you see them Brian,
and you realize how big they are and how
fast they move,
you know like you know how fast they are
from like zero to their top speed,
they're are almost equal to a dirt bike.
She,
I think they can run 40.
Oh my God,
they can go like their torque ratio is
very fast.
If they're running,
they're going to catch you.
Oh my God.
I think if one was within 20 yards and
then started like with full intent to
come,
I think you would think about turning
and he would get maybe two strides and
that thing that thing's giving you the
Leonardo Dicaprio to the back.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah,
look up that.
What is the speed of those things?
You Know Adam Green tree,
he encountered one when he was in
Montana.
He had shot an elk and he was packing
the elk out by himself.
He was deep in the back country by
himself.
Yeah,
that was,
I think it was 12 plus miles in,
right?
Something like that.
Yeah.
She cuts off Adam.
Adam's an animal and so he goes in
there,
he shoots his elk.
That was wrong.
45 Oh,
it's even faster.
What's like speed of the speeding on the
residential street?
Yeah.
You couldn't go through a school zone on
the grizzly go zero to 45 times.
So Adam's packing his grizzly,
excuse me,
packing this elk out that he shot by
himself.
I mean,
he went in there with an archery tag,
like it was a,
it was an an an over the counter unit.
It goes in like 12,
12 miles into public land.
Amen.
Public hacked it out himself,
which if you know the numbers,
it's gotta be somewhere in the
neighborhood of 500 pounds of meat.
Right.
Well,
depending on the fee or not,
he had that other,
his friend of his at works for a trophy
taker,
right?
Yeah.
Grant Grant.
And he helped him carry it out after a
while.
Actually I had just left Montana.
I went to Montana and hunted eastern
Montana for me these,
but for my,
for my elk tag,
it was only in a general unit.
So I had to come back.
I literally left Montana and drove home,
um,
to see Sharon for two days to then drive
back.
And when I was driving home,
I was following Adam's instagram story
of impact in that sucker.
I was the,
like if I didn't have a wife at home,
I was this close to just texting him and
saying,
where are you dude?
Cause I was gonna like come help him
out.
Well he could definitely get people to
do that for him.
That'd be a cool thing too.
People would love to go meet Adam Green
Tree.
Yeah.
Help him pack out.
That's the one of the cool things about
hunting is how many like really
considerate,
like really friendly,
helpful people we met on this weekend.
Yeah we did.
We were there and and guide had a
membership out there and had his camper.
They're totally kept to himself and on
his last day when he was coming out,
he saw us and he's like,
Hey dudes,
I've been on this really cool big red
boar that I saw and you know,
literally told us like go up here,
turn here,
go here.
I haven't been able to get on him.
I mean the guy was like genuinely
helpful to another hunter and you know
that 100% is what we need.
Society really.
We need everyone to just like help one
another out when it's possible.
I mean you're going to have pettiness in
every single group of humans,
but I think overall the tone that I've
experienced from people that are
involved in hunting,
very helpful,
very respectful,
sounds crazy to those people,
but I think that they have,
by being in nature and experiencing the
life and death moments in nature,
I think what it addresses a certain part
of them in their place,
in the food chain that almost like comms
and internal aspect of people that are
involved in it because the,
the real struggle,
the life and death struggle of consuming
meat is undeniable.
Yeah.
In terms of like what it means,
like this is what it means,
the animals to die,
you have to cut it up.
You Cook it,
eat it.
That's the PR.
It's not going to the restaurant and I
don't know what happened.
You can't,
I can't,
I don't know what happened that I don't
know what happened is the problem.
It's not the hunting.
That's the problem.
It's that 95% of the people,
95 that's a big number,
but what percentage of them have ever
even seen it happen?
What percentage of them have done it
themselves?
What percent?
I mean,
you don't have to,
you definitely don't have to.
I'm just,
I'm mean,
we're just talking.
I'm not passing any judgment on people
know that I have in the past.
Sure.
Let me ask you this right now.
This is one thing I thought about the
other day.
How many people have gone,
they've ordered something like that and
then they don't eat it all.
So they throw it in the trashcan.
Yeah,
that happened.
But it,
but doing what you are.
I do.
Do you look at that differently?
It's definitely different.
Like if you cooked an elk roast,
which I mean,
that's not even fair that I'm bringing
this up because we,
we did it the first night I came in,
but if you cooked an elk gross and you
didn't need it all,
would you do?
Would you dump that into the trash?
No,
no,
no.
I eat it.
And what else don't eat?
I feed to my chickens and people go
like,
someone said this to me like,
yeah,
you think that's natural man.
A chicken eating and elk.
I'm like,
I'm telling you,
it's just meet your chicken is a goddamn
murdered motherfucker.
I need to come off it.
Your chicken is more ruthless and more
murderous than any cat you've ever met.
They are God damn dinosaurs.
Well,
didn't they say velociraptors
technically a dinosaur chicken,
right?
Some in somehow or another like like uh,
ancient Australia.
Pithy kiss is a human of today.
Like that,
that chain of progress.
Yeah.
Somehow or another,
a dinosaur became a chicken.
Some kind of little raptor ma.
They are fucking ruthless man.
I've met some people that must have
definitely been t rex got a couple of
friends where they're so pumped how much
more they can bench.
But when they're like doing it about
four inches,
I'm like,
what is up dude?
How you x bench?
Yeah.
People love to do more impressive
numbers incorrectly.
Right?
Yeah.
Very true.
That's one of the things that gets
people hurt more than anything.
Lifting weights.
Like one time this guy,
he emasculated me in a,
in the gym and Phoenix,
some giant fucking football player.
Dude.
You know,
he'd met me with a dairy man.
Big Fan.
You know,
love you bro.
You still phone?
Do you have sue's really know your shit.
Oh thanks dude.
Thanks very much.
And this dude is over there like just
doing stacks,
just stack squats and he's just a
fucking Herculean like 300 pound man and
I'm over there doing a kettlebell
workout with 35 pounds like a bitch.
I was doing 35 pound windmills.
I was doing like these slow moving
kettle bell,
but I'm like look man,
I know this is not the same thing as
what you're doing but you don't do this
either.
Do you?
Yeah,
like doing like slow stuff live with
lightweights.
Controlled stuff is good for your body
to,
it's like guys get it in their head.
They've got to be floating on bench and
nine 50 bro.
When you doing this like you can't move,
you got to,
your body's got a move that's all about
free range.
The best thing I did was went down on
your recommendation.
I flew down to the onnit academy and met
all those guys and spent I think two
days in there and just said I
want to do everything.
Show me the May,
show me kettle bells.
You know,
I did some stuff on rings,
um,
did some stuff on Bungee straps and it's
all,
I mean,
and you see people that have conditions,
they've worked out that way and
something real simple.
And then you have someone that's,
you know,
I'm six,
five to 30 to 20,
probably two 30 after hunting camp.
Um,
and they're doing these simple movements
to where you just feel like a Wussy.
There's people that are that
structurally and core wise or so sound
and actually movable muscle and usable
muscle.
It's totally different than only only
certain types of weights that most
people do.
When I met Frank Zane years ago and I
went and trained with him on my weight
training specifically on freeways,
I felt like I had wasted.
I met him when I met,
I think I met him maybe in my late
twenties and at that point I'd been
working out maybe 15 years.
And I told him,
I said,
I feel like I've wasted 15 years of like
really trying to improve myself.
But I realize now how inefficient I was.
And then when I've started to learn some
of these movements that are about,
you know,
real body usage strength,
I feel the same way.
I'm like I wish when I was in high
school my football coach would have been
having people do windmills because
they're talking about how,
you know,
you go to wrestling practice,
everyone's talking about how important
it is to be solid.
But everything was like bench,
squat,
deadlift.
I mean things like what we just talked
about with like a windmill.
It's totally different.
I mean
bend,
squat,
squat deadlift is still the kings.
But I just think that people get a
little bit kings for total mass,
right?
Just get people,
get a little caught up in the numbers
and to the point where they're willing
to ignore the form.
And I think that's where a lot of people
get hurt.
It's like a real problem with people
being a little bit too macho.
And I fucking absolutely have been
guilty of that while I was lifting
weight.
Too much weight.
Just like,
cause I can bro,
cause I could do it bro.
I tried to Max out on one 35 months.
One 35 would mean for bench.
Oh,
like as many times as you can.
I tried to get it once.
I didn't get it.
Oh is that a joke?
I got confused.
Sorry.
I don't joke around with the enough.
You actually took me serious.
I definitely did.
It might be a problem.
No,
I need to screw around with anymore.
I saw brock Lesnar's a,
you ever seen his um,
uh,
his,
you know those,
uh,
the times they do when they're trying
out for football?
What's that shit called again?
Combine?
Yes.
The combine scores.
They had brock lesnar versus Shane car
when it was like a big heavyweight fight
cause it was too super powerful.
Really dangerous wrestlers in,
when you look at the combine scores,
you realize what a freak brock lesner
is.
Well I saw him ringside with you.
Oh,
he's a freak.
He's a freak.
It's just straight viking DNA
from the motherland.
If I was a little guy coming from Asia
with my whole family and I had to walk
up to fat dude,
I would think the same thing as a short
faced bears.
I'd be like,
wait,
I have to go by that.
Then flat,
if that fucking thing,
brick and traps,
I have to go by that.
Screw that.
Let's go back and get some Sushi dudes.
If that thing pulls up in a boat,
you fucked up right you,
you,
you're in the wrong place.
Imagine that being in war in a viking
ship comes up like 300 of those suckers
coming off rock lester's,
jump off the boat.
Fuck this life.
It's been real.
That'd be ripping my undies off.
Holding up a white flag real fast.
Kind of what we're talking about though,
when we're talking about the short face
bear,
I mean there's like levels of these
animals,
there's levels of all these animals and
they reach a state of balance.
And one of the weird things that I
experienced this weekend and I've
experienced before while wild pig
hunting is,
it's almost like you see something that
other people are not seeing.
It's like you,
where you realized you look at it,
you a,
hey,
this could be a giant problem.
This can be a giant problem.
And it's also like you don't have to go
to the grocery store to get pork.
Like in fact,
that's probably not the best way to do
it.
What we really should do is stop doing
that and go shoot those legal ones.
You know?
I mean,
in California we don't have,
there's no limit.
Great Way to do it.
They don't have a limit in California.
All
the,
all the hog farmers or like,
you know
what?
Yeah,
well,
I know,
seriously,
listen,
why don't we do that?
Is there a,
is there a,
I wonder if we have like a food bank or
something to where,
you know,
if we're out for the,
for the places given food to the
homeless,
why aren't we out doing some,
uh,
pork lips is,
and bringing in some serious pork chops
for people.
Get Chad out there from whiskey bent
barbecue,
get him doing some pulled pork butts,
the homeless shelters.
That'd be ridiculous.
Trager would sponsor go homeless.
Just eat there.
But I would,
yeah,
but I don't think you're allowed to use
wild animals.
Oh,
that because,
no,
I think it has to do.
Nope.
No,
you can stop.
[inaudible] Iowa.
We have a really good program called
hush.
No,
no,
that's not what you mean.
I need,
I don't mean like a donation.
I mean like selling it.
Like if you wanted to like sell it,
like one of the things about wild game,
wild pork,
I think you can,
can,
don't know can commercialize the wires
commercial people now doing.
Um,
cause I know when we were in
Indianapolis,
I cooked,
I cooked elk tacos and the eastern
booth,
but we had to actually get a license,
FDA,
elk farmer to provide the meat I
couldn't bring.
So that is the disconnect if you raise
it.
But then again,
you're like raising a hog in
a,
it's not the same.
No,
it won't be.
What conditions aren't even near the
same?
Well,
you know the,
you know what the one guy has got it
down as Joel Salitan diverse here,
heard of that guy.
He's got a,
of an organization called polyface farms
and uh,
had him on the podcast.
He's fascinating because he's a real old
school farmer,
but really smart.
And what he realized somewhere along the
line is that these animals are only
happy when they're living like animals
and you get better product from better
food.
It's healthier.
So he takes his pigs and he has his
traveling fence so he puts a fence up
and he makes it like really big and then
they fuck everything up on this one side
of the fence.
Then he moves the fence like having
goats or chickens or whatever.
Is it just an enormous sense,
a good fresh ecosystem?
Yeah.
And it also recycles all the ground the
ground and grow better grass everywhere.
They took a dump,
you know.
So he does that with chickens too.
He has this gigantic mobile chicken unit
and he pushed this thing around and he
lets you just chickens out and they all
run around.
They do chicken shit and they go back up
into their little houses when it gets
dark out,
they know where their houses.
So he moves them around too.
It's really,
really interesting,
man,
because this kid,
it's less of a disconnect and some
people were uncomfortable with there
being less of a disconnect.
Some people like to just get a chicken
sandwich.
I don't know how the fuck you got in
that sandwich with thanks dude.
Here's your five bucks,
got to go.
And then there's other people that go,
okay,
what does a chicken,
it gets a little cunty dinosaur thing.
I still run once a eat your kids.
That's what a chicken is like.
I have chickens that I love them.
They're sweethearts.
I pick him up and I pet them.
I mean,
they're like pegs.
They make great eggs.
Yeah,
but the bottom line is that's a country
little dinosaur and we're lucky.
That thing is smaller than us.
It's bigger than I said.
What?
Fuck us up.
You know?
It's true.
We're so weak as humans when we go out.
I mean,
don't make me bring up the terror bird.
No,
you know about the terror bird?
North American.
Tera Byrd.
Is that the one bigger than the Eagle?
It's like nine feet tall,
dude.
Who was a nine foot tall,
gigantic bird that didn't fly and it
lived in North America.
So it was an ostrich pull up.
It was an,
it was predatory.
No,
but it was a dinosaur.
Ostrich.
Bigger.
Look how big it was.
That's what it looked like.
It looks like a nutcracker.
There's a scale,
whether it show it next to a human look
how fucking big it was.
Are you kidding me?
Why was everything bigger?
Dude?
I don't know.
Have you ever seen that movie?
Have you ever seen that movie,
honey?
I shrunk the kids.
Did that happen on earth?
Look at that terror,
Byrd and the short face bur burp a bear
together.
Look at that right there.
Oh Jeez.
Click on that Jamie.
No,
the next one.
The next one.
The one above it.
That's the short face bear,
isn't it?
No,
no.
The the like the drawing.
That one right there that your cursor is
on.
Oh Gosh.
Go Up to the top left.
That's another short facebook saber
tooth cat.
Oh it is.
Are Cool.
Okay.
I love
cats or sort.
I mean cow shit killing me at a certain
line.
Cats and bears start looking kind of
similar.
No.
Yeah.
That's kind of bear like a little bit,
isn't it?
But faster,
bigger teeth,
faster,
bigger teeth.
Faster with less power.
Look at that bird up there.
What's in its mouth?
Jesus
riding it.
Joy of Google and he's a game.
Actually.
It is.
Oh,
the park.
I would ride that thing.
Listen,
we've got a real problem with these
genetic engineers.
All of these like super geeks out there.
Why don't those are assholes,
decides to recreate one of these things
and keep it around like William Randolph
hearst the year 2017 if that Dick had
just brings,
instead of bringing it around wild hogs,
he brings around terror birds.
Don't worry of domesticated them.
They're all vegetarian now that I seek
in ride him.
I thought he was pretty cool.
I don't think you can do it.
I don't.
It says upper class.
If you,
if you pull up to your car spot and it
says like Joe Rogan parking is you ride
up on a t bird.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Would anybody who would take your spot
if they ride up on a bird?
What,
what year did that thing go extinct?
The terror bird.
Yeah,
it's gotta be prehistoric.
We'll definitely create a stork.
Definitely.
That's one of the main points of
evidence that I always use when people
talk about big foot.
Like how come you don't,
I know you don't believe big floods that
really anymore.
I'm like I don't,
it's not that I don't believe it's real,
but I,
I have a very hard time believing that
hunters haven't seen him.
What if I'm the reason all these cool
animals are extinct?
It's cause they walked off the edge of
the earth.
That's a good point,
dude.
They,
they passed the ice wall.
There's an ice wall out there.
He can't pass it.
Super important.
Standing inside the ice wall.
There are reports from Uruguay of
finding stating to 450,000 and 17,000
years ago,
but the claim is debated so immensely.
Wow.
That's as close as we get.
62 to 1.8 million years ago is the
actual normal thought of range even
though it doesn't leave it look area.
I tried to keep an open mind about this
flat earth thing and I said try to keep
an open mind.
Well,
I just,
I kind of wanted to hear the other
side's argument just so I can
understand.
I get what it is,
man.
I think it's just the lack of
communication.
I think what we need is like,
and I know Neil degrasse Tyson had this
conversation with Bob,
right?
That's the,
the rapper's name,
but kind of explained it to him and Bob
dissed him.
A flat earth support track or some,
I don't know.
It's,
I just think it's just a lack of
communication.
It's like someone needs to explain to
people in a way that doesn't offend
their preconceived notions because
people get this idea that they have the
right information about something.
They think that something is wrong and
they,
they get married to that idea.
If you go,
you'll like Shaq who just recently came
out and said he's married to the idea
that the world is flat.
It's like
how much research you doing?
Don't
be,
you know,
are you not pay me how much,
how much research are the people on the
space station doing?
Are they all in on a lie?
They're all in on a lie.
Is that real or did you decide that
that's real and now you're looking only
at things that support that idea in your
head and you're not looking for it
through astrophysicists or astronauts or
people that study it their whole life
who understand it.
You're not looking at it through those
lenses.
That's why it seems like it makes sense.
It only seems like it makes sense cause
you don't know what makes sense.
How dare you,
I my Baiting,
I'm not even focusing on the shack.
Think we all are just,
we're all silly.
All of us on both sides.
It's not even that.
Just at the people that believe the
earth is flat.
I've got three full passports with
stamps.
I think.
I feel for the people that believe it,
cause I think some of them didn't tell
them correctly or something.
But I've never done an international
flight where I flew for a while and then
the plane banked,
it turned around.
It doesn't work that way.
It's like a black hole.
He hit the wall,
the ice wall.
And then you go back in time to the
moment when you're born is the ice with
your life over and over again.
The ice wall real though.
Fuck yes.
No one's been there and take pictures of
it,
but they can't because of the Illuminati
and plus the Jews know what Pr.
You can't just go to the ice wall,
dude.
Jamie,
I'm asking you as a third party.
It was a simple question to joe of
sorry.
So what happens when you get to the
edge?
I wish I was an expert and he said,
let's just make shit up.
So,
but is there an ice wall or was that,
it was cause I actually thought that was
part of the argument.
Yes,
no,
that is part of the argument.
But the,
the part of the argument started,
wait a minute,
are you kidding me?
It sounds like the Truman show or like
hunger games.
I don't fault anybody who believes on
your end.
I think there's a problem when someone
believes something and then someone else
doesn't believe what they believe.
And then on both sides there's a is
there's an issue because the side that
believes that they're right,
the side of the astronomers and
astrophysicists,
we get angry,
get angry at people that believe
something other than what we are pretty
sure to be true.
So you start making it into personal
thing and it's stupid,
you know?
And I think that's part of the problems
that people get invested in their ideas.
You get invested in the idea of big
foot.
I was fucking 100% over invested in the
idea of big foot.
I was super helpful or hopeful.
Rather every time I would see a new
story about big foot,
please let this be the one I was
thinking about it man.
It was like if they really found bigfoot
I crazy.
Would that be fuck yeah.
But then it did make sense.
It didn't make sense.
No.
Sharon actually brought up a very valid
point.
She said if there was a big foot,
it's like what's his age limit?
Yeah,
because he's got,
I mean by now,
that sucker based on like how long
monkeys
and stuff live or a bear or whatever.
He's gone.
If there was one,
the idea is that there's a population of
them.
I've talked to several experts.
What's that going to see any updates on
big foot.
Oh please.
They're excellent.
Rob Lowe and his sons are going to hunt
big foot for Ada.
That'll be a fun show.
Rob Lowe's,
a funny guy.
Hello files.
I think that'd be interesting,
but is it,
look,
they're doing it like that.
He really thinks he's going to find it,
or is he doing it as a way like,
okay boys,
I'm going to prove to you that this is
kind of,
maybe it's not even preconceived or
maybe it's scripted.
The little side streets.
Well,
you know who absolutely.
100% is balls deep in bigfoot bobcat.
Goldthwait balls and I love that pot.
I love him.
He's awesome.
He was really cool.
He actually grew leaves actually
believes at that video.
You know that Patterson footage with the
things walking across the field.
He thinks of it all the time
that that Bob Patterson guide met you.
You probably could have taken the place,
the other guy,
that muscle,
if I had as much hair as you did without
shaving.
Oh,
they're in like up here.
I think I could look like that sucker.
Like if he seen me stock in that hog
this morning,
he'd be like,
there was a fricking big foot doing
yoga.
Well,
there's some dudes that get real hairy
and we've got to assume that the
Harriers dude that we know today ain't
shit compared to the Harissa student of
a hundred years ago.
Right.
If you didn't have clothes,
you know,
you'd be growing some hair.
Yeah,
for sure.
Seriously.
Yeah.
If you were cold,
if you had to live or die,
you would grow hair.
Why would it be any different than a dog
that sheds when it's hot or grows here
when it's cold?
Because we're not animals.
John Dudley where people came from.
Monkeys don't tell people that they
don't want to believe it.
Wow.
Yeah,
super hairy people and if your kind like
big giant freak like dudes like you're
kind of covered with hair.
We're so opposite.
Actually.
You and I,
I know.
I'm like sitting there thinking do what
I want to be.
I feel like a tire.
I feel like he's,
he's my child.
When we hug,
I'm his child brother.
I Dunno,
but I feel like,
remember when you told me that story
about the monkey that you had,
that you had when you were on fear
factor chimp,
Pete my ass.
When you held that little thing you
thought this thing's made a would that,
that's what I feel when I get you up on
my shoulder.
I'm like,
damn,
this thing's made a would
absolutely start.
I was telling Jamie,
I think I've told you this story.
I've probably told it to everybody.
I've met that I have a little baby chimp
on the set of news radio.
Like way back in the day.
It was supposed to be in some stuff that
I tell you this,
I probably said it before.
This little motherfucker was on my back
and he hit me a couple times and I was
stunned.
I was like,
oh no,
this is not what I thought.
It was like.
I thought it was like a little person
like,
oh,
this little person thinks he's a bad
ass.
Let me just calm him down now.
He got on top of the page,
just hit me a couple times on the back
and I was like,
what in the fuck?
I just was thinking it immediately.
I started doing the math in my head and
thinking what it would be like to be
confronted by a full grown chimp.
Okay,
well that's my argument with the silver
back versus grizzly.
You said Grizzly because grizzlies or
even more and more of the fucking bad
ass than a chimp.
Grizzly.
Grizzly can't like,
there's no way a chimp can outrun a
grizzly.
There's no way,
not a chance in hell.
What's this?
I don't know if that's true.
What is a silver back?
Full speed.
I seen one of those things.
No grizzly can outrun a soda.
I know it.
I'm straight.
I feel confident.
I think chimps are fast.
The gorillas and I think at Grizzly can
out run a chimp and I think for me,
I think there's no way the guerrillas
getting fucked.
He's getting ds.
Dude.
I'm telling you right now,
big ass and tiering your hands feel like
when they shake mine and so I would be,
I guess I'm not like a Grizzly,
but you're a giant dude.
It
would crumple you like empty pop.
It wouldn't even,
it would even be like,
he wouldn't even feel you.
He would go through you like whipped
cream fee,
25 miles an hour.
Top speed.
What does it say?
Feels like 25 and 25 similar animals
speeds 34 but it feels like 25 I don't
understand.
What that means is from someone riding
it's back.
Get to a different website.
Is that really what this is?
Oh my God,
I love the name.
What pd?
Where'd that come from?
Do you know where that came from?
For elk speed of animals.com
a wall pd?
Yeah.
What does it,
where does that word come?
That's what an elk is,
dude.
Why the,
it's actually a whopper who called it
the [inaudible].
What does that,
where does that name come from?
I've heard it.
It's a cool name.
[inaudible] Wednesday is the Hashtag.
Cam uses it a lot.
Powerful wapatee Wednesday
is a champ.
I said a silver back.
I don't want to know what my gap is.
So do you think a chimp is faster?
Jump off there,
don't you think in chip is faster than a
gorilla?
[inaudible] silver back.
Okay.
Have you seen a silver back come out of
the fricking past
told you so?
Yes.
What I'm thinking though,
speaking of restraints,
it's,
it's just like an archery argument.
Yeah.
Maybe.
I think the bear gets a heavier arrow,
slower speed,
fast Arrow,
but there's not much of a difference in
the speed.
It's real close and a grizzly bear is so
much bigger.
Moving so much more mass around,
like have a big grizzly is 500 pounds a
silver back.
I'm pretty sure.
I mean a big grizzly interior,
grizzly,
what does a big one,
like 900 is that really not a mountain
grizzly?
You can look it up.
I would say aggressive ones.
Just say six or 700 and the really big
ones that the coastal ones,
right,
which they call brown bears for
years.
Why do they call them that?
But because it's the same animal,
different specie,
is it?
Yes.
Yeah.
They don't interbreed or anything
bigger.
The break.
Totally different bear.
Yeah.
One looks like a Volkswagen with hair
and one looks more like a Ford truck or
one of those other things where the the
one that has the scare,
your name is like not the biggest one,
which is weird.
Like Brown bear sounded like,
oh,
he's so cuddly.
And you see those buses under brainiac
island.
So coke.
Yeah,
Klondike bars.
Well,
that's right.
What would you do for a Klondike Bar?
I fucking poor because your buddy,
I'm your buddy.
I live in a place where there's no
vegetables.
It's a conspiracy theory.
Told her bears brought that up.
They literally made those to make
themselves look cuddly.
So humans would be stupid enough to walk
up to him.
Do you think it's like a nature trick?
Like nature made them cool to look at?
So we don't mind as much that they're
murderers.
I would argue Disney fucking Disney,
right?
Like that Bambi movie [inaudible] slower
by 10 miles an hour.
The,
is there anyone that has the doctor told
you?
No.
But is there any strength of a silver
back versus a grizzly?
And I say this saying,
I really respect grizzly bears and brown
bears cause you know that,
well I feel that the concerns of a lot
of grizzly bears and brown bears that
were listening and they were there,
they're pumped.
I think that um,
they're all dangerous and ferocious and
I'm thinking silver back versus the
nigger is you think you would win?
Yeah.
Maybe people who listen to this podcast
and he said put it in the pot and the
pose what we need to know,
what people want to know.
I wouldn't want to fight a 38 pound rat.
I be fucking terrified to fight at 38
pound rat.
So the idea of 38 I just can't put a
number cause that's a fucking giant rat
man.
Yeah,
but he should have said 30 40.
I know,
but like [inaudible]
what's a house cat weigh like 10 pounds.
No Way.
That's the Garfield waste.
10.
Okay.
Like seven,
seven pounds.
I'm like that.
I would think something along those
lines.
Okay,
now,
now make it bigger.
Like keep like a what?
What size is it becomes unmanageable.
First off,
let's,
if you're not wearing welding gloves at
10 pound in shape house cat,
you're not talking like Garfield,
you're talking like,
I dunno.
Let's talk about a conor Mcgregor
Garfield at coming in at 10.
Like a real good tiger cat.
Like one of them,
you know those,
those ones like real common house cat
ones that look like a little picture of
this pic.
If you grabbed a 10 pound mountain line,
do you think you can control that?
There's no way.
My neighbor,
my neighbor,
it's 38 pound.
My neighbors,
good buddy of mine.
And He,
uh,
he saw a mountain lion and uh,
he saw a mountain lion when he was
walking his dogs get these little cutie
dogs.
He's walking this little cutie dogs and
he saw this fucking thing,
so its tail and picked it up,
picked the dogs up and ran back to his
house and then got on a website,
got on a website and found out that,
uh,
that,
that they attract this animal and that
it a,
it had a collar on it and the tracked it
and it got hit by a car on the five and
he's explaining like how the whole,
the whole thing went down.
I was like,
Whoa,
like that you were walking your dogs and
this big ass cat,
it's like 120 pound plus cat.
So the actual cat that had a collar,
he knew that's the one he encountered.
Yeah,
yeah.
He saw,
he saw the collar and then he went on
the website and you can track because
he'd,
he'd found out that this cat had died
and when he found out the cat died,
he went and uh oh the sound of whiskey.
Are you good?
Yeah,
I'm good dude.
Trust me you're yet,
he's talking a lot of stupid shit.
I even touch that.
I definitely have.
How dare you.
You one of those guys bro.
You ain't even been drunk cause me bro.
Quit bullying me.
Sorry.
It's my instinct.
What we were just,
what,
what the fuck was I just getting to you?
I had on the rat.
Oh yeah.
Among other things.
So a silver back is essentially like a
super,
a super prime it right.
The most super,
super prime.
Yes.
But a bear is one of the most super,
Super Freak Predator animal freak out.
Things like have a bear was little,
like a nine pound bear.
Like the size of a nine pound rat was
trying to kill you.
You'd be freaking the fuck out if it was
running annual,
like a little tiny bear.
You'd be fucking terrified.
Now think of a giant one and realize how
pr you,
you are totally defenseless and I don't
think it's going to be that much
difference.
For average.
Literally think of a silver back gorilla
with the way they're built and they
swing around.
I think if he stood on the chest of a
grizzly can grab its paws and literally
rip its arms out and beat it with it.
Wow.
That's King Kong was a good movie.
I agree with you there.
I enjoyed it as much as the next day,
I think in a Kong,
but I believe that.
I don't think that's correct.
I don't think they're that strong.
The thumb,
the thumb doves does give an advantage
though,
right?
It could grab,
wait,
it's a little smarter.
Move around a little fast,
Jamie.
Hmm,
great.
But he just,
the bears way stronger.
Way Stronger.
It could smack at once.
I've seen that.
I've seen a grown mountain grizzly hit a
moose and cannon.
Yeah.
You told me that,
that I've seen you saw it with your own
eyes.
Right.
Is there any solid information of
strength of a silver back for,
there's not,
there's just a lot of people that have
argued this on the Internet for the last
five to 10 we get dangerously close to
this argument.
Seriously.
Why don't they put thor's hammer on the
ground have and like put a,
put a Taco in it or something to where a
grizzly has to try to grab it and pull
it off and have a sensor versus the
silver back down.
Well,
the grizzly definitely can't grab as
hard because it doesn't have thumbs like
we talked about,
but I think,
yeah,
but that's relative to a beating,
right?
Who,
how many fighters have a big ass and a
lot of like leg power krakoff versus
someone that's just sheer grill up top.
I'm,
let's do go there.
I just wonder how strong a gorilla
really is in comparison to which
essentially like a giant dog.
I just think he's going to get far
crazy.
You think silver back is equivalent to a
giant dog,
a bearers?
What I'm saying is a bear.
A bear is like essentially like a giant
house.
Well,
why would I call it silver back dog?
I Dunno.
We've had a couple of adult beverage.
Yeah,
and we had a fun time this weekend,
man.
We'd really fun time,
Dude.
You John Dudley's the greatest archery
coach in the world there.
I said it,
but even though I only have experience
with John Today,
but I'm telling you,
he knows his shit to the point where I
can,
I highly doubt that.
Uh,
does anybody's more detail oriented than
you?
He do it.
Sharon told me that.
She said a lot of times you'll give a
compliment to me,
but then you'll immediately say
something that contradicts it.
Like I'll say,
say I say,
I really love those shoes.
Those shoes look really good.
And then I'll,
without knowing it,
say those silver ones that you have or
better or whatever,
just say it.
You know,
whatever.
You kind of did that to me.
He said,
I'm a,
I was a good coach,
but I've only had one.
I know though.
I know what you're doing though.
You're so good research though,
Dude.
You just show it.
It's,
you stopped me.
Archery is fascinating.
It's such a fascinating thing.
I am definitely a stalker in a Weirdo,
especially when it comes to archery,
but like learning it and learning from a
guy who's like such a,
the way you break the whole thing down
is so fascinating because you expose
these little weaknesses.
I've seen you do it and he did it this
weekend with uh,
our friend Steve or this week with Steve
Ryan who he hung out with.
Yeah.
Super Cool Dude.
Awesome beard.
Really cool guy.
It's definitely work at shaving shortly.
Manly beard or Roche,
mostly manly beer.
But I saw you just tune in his ball.
You fixed a few things about his stance.
Like you can't help yourself as soon as
you see someone and you were,
you were,
you're so bored with it at this point.
You started asking me what is he doing
wrong and like what's wrong here?
No,
I did that for a reason.
That was part of me coaching you this
weekend actually.
Oh,
well it worked and it was seriously
true.
The video was the best part.
Like showing me a video of the that in
later.
That was awesome.
Everything was strategic.
Actually,
I asked you what you thought of him
because a big part of me knowing that
I'm teaching the right way is once my
students are able to identify when I'm
not there.
I think that's a very important thing
that coaches miss is some coaches,
they want the money,
they want the student dependent on you
being there all the time.
They want to go with you to the
tournament.
They want to go with you to the UFC
fight,
whatever.
But the reality is like with me
personally,
thankfully if I agree to work with
someone,
the reality is I don't get to see you
every week.
A lot of the people that I work with,
I picked because I really want to,
I enjoy working with them,
but I want you to be able to help
yourself when I'm not there.
Cause I mean both of you and I only get
to see each other every three months
maybe.
So if I'm not able to be there seeing
shooting for three months,
am I a good coach?
Because you're,
you know,
for whatever 89 days,
you're wondering if you're doing it
right.
So when I asked you that it was,
it was for a reason because I thought if
you ever called me and said,
am I doing something wrong?
I could be able to say,
well,
have your ticket,
take a picture and look.
Because hopefully we've worked on the
same things enough to where you're able
to identify.
I want you to be able to tell me what
you're doing wrong.
And I think,
I think a good coach does that.
They're secure to do that.
I don't want to have to,
I don't want my students to be dependent
on me.
I want them to,
I want to push myself because I'm
wondering,
do you know as much as I do right now
and can I take this to another level
where I introduce you to something new?
Well,
you know,
this is something that I've experienced
in a big way with Jujitsu that the very
best coaches,
not only do they not hold anything back,
but they,
they encourage their students to be as
good as them or better.
Like my friend Eddie Bravo is a perfect
example of that.
He has like this whole team of top
killers,
like he's,
he's really put together this
fascinating style and now has
incorporated all these leg locks into
it.
This fascinating style of Jujitsu and
openly encourages any new moves explores
and gives everyone credit and they all,
they're all battling it out trying to
come up with the best method for every
single situation.
And the only way to do that is to
encourage growth,
to not be afraid of competition,
to embrace losing to your students are
getting tapped by your students.
That's great.
It keeps everyone on their toes and
other martial arts don't do that.
Oh I shouldn't say they don't do that,
but it's way less common than the Jiu
Jitsu community.
Like John Jacques Machado is a perfect
example.
Like he's,
he's the guy who gave Eddie Bravo's
blackbelt and John Jacques Machado was
like completely dedicated to making his
students as good as him or better.
Like that's,
that's his hundred percent focus.
And when you do that,
all you're concentrating on is the
growth and the improvement of the art.
The actual art of Jujitsu.
And I think the same could be said for
archery.
Like you're not trying to hold anything
back.
You're trying to show,
it's,
you're trying to put it into someone's
head so they could do the very best job
they can at,
at minimizing all the things that can go
wrong,
tune everything right.
And then you'll know what you're doing.
You'll be able to take steps and it's,
it's real similar in a lot of ways.
It's real similar.
Well,
like with Eddy say he knew one move so
he knew the crane kick,
right?
That how dare you.
Who doesn't involve pain?
I just stepped out of your leg is
terrible.
Son of a gun,
sorry.
Every,
I'm sorry.
Every 10th player,
Jujitsu Guy Ludwig.
Actually use that in a fight.
Dwayne Bang.
Ludwig is such a motherfucker who was
beaten this dude up and in the middle of
beating it was in the king of the cage
in the middle of beating the dude up.
He goes into the crane kick and this was
when Duane Ludwig,
he still a motherfucker,
don't get me wrong,
but this was when Duane Ludwig was a
young buck wild motherfucker and he was
boss Rutan's protege.
So he's fighting this guy in Caney cage
and his standup is just super advanced
for MMA at this point.
People just did not know what the fuck
to do with this guy.
He had just wicked stand up and was
very,
um,
very competent and very successful as a
professional.
Kickboxer too.
He's just super good striker fought,
you know Ramon dekkers fought like top
level Moy Thai guys.
I mean he was a really,
really impressive guy.
So when he was in mma,
and this is Kinda,
he did kind of both of them at the same
time too when he was in mma and when he
did his crane kick on this guide,
MMA was just not level ready for this
level striking yet.
He's Tj dillashaw star coach,
you know he is right.
He's beat this dude up.
Look at this.
No.
Is it wash it for a little bit because
when you watch like how good he was back
then,
you know it's still is not soap fucking
technical like see all these
combinations he threw.
He was like on another level back then.
But compared to a good percentage of the
people that fought in mma,
like the kitties fighting is wearing
shoes.
Okay.
Just wondering skate after this.
I mean he's getting lit up now.
This is like Duane Bang,
kick,
jump head kicked him.
I know.
Ooh,
this dude is getting,
look at this.
He likes combination.
No question.
Come on.
Cowboy combinations right there,
but no question.
I'm feeling like I'm an eighth grade
basketball looking at those shorts.
Dude,
you're so tall.
I accidentally touched her feet and
there were all the way the fuck over
here.
I was trying to,
it's ridiculous.
You can go ahead.
I got real mad.
Don't worry about,
hey,
she touched my knees.
That's ridiculous cause that your knee.
Yeah man,
that's my knee.
Be careful you don't have any brb
we were talking about bouncy road
boners.
If there is something that happens to a
man when he's in a car that's going down
a bouncy road for too long,
when he was like,
what is it,
rod in my pants.
It's weird,
right?
Yeah.
It's like spaceballs that darth helmet.
I never saw that.
He should.
I definitely probably should make sure
you're in the mood to see it.
Really dumb movie.
You know,
sometimes I think when you did the
podcast with Leah,
you said there's some movies that are so
bad that they're actually good.
Like baseball's is it?
Oh,
is it really supposed to be?
That's John Candy,
isn't it?
I thought it was supposed to be really
fun.
It is.
So it's just procrastinate as a dog.
I watched part of it.
I think once,
it's one of the like really big flaws in
my catalog,
my catalog of movies I've watched,
I've missed a lot of like really good
movies you have that never saw Bruno the
allergy movie.
I heard it was amazing.
I never,
I saw Bora love dad left dead and I
should have seen bruce,
but I have never seen Bruno.
I had never seen Barat and we're at
Sharon sister's house and they're like,
what you haven't seen borats is her
sister and Sharon and her sister both
like,
you know they walked pretty straight
line,
you know that.
And she said,
oh you cause her sister watched her
sister watches like horror movies and
like scary movies or at movies.
Sharon and I are more into like,
you know,
we'd like funny movie stepbrothers stuff
like that tell they get nights but she
told her husband to put bore add on and
when he put it on and like,
I don't know if when he put the CD on,
if it likes started up where they
stopped before,
but it was literally when Barat was like
69 in that fat guy
in the bed and she's like,
no,
just wait.
It's really good.
And we're just sitting there like,
what the hell is this?
Yeah,
you can't just enter in the middle of
that movie.
You have to start from the beginning.
We literally,
I don't know for like timeline,
but it started at fat guy at 69 that's
where it started.
And we were like,
wait a minute,
this is good.
Yeah.
That guy is capable of keeping a
straight face and tremendous
circumstances.
Like I don't know what he has in him,
but he has a fucking constitution of
steel.
The way he doesn't break character while
these people,
like he was my,
remember when he was carrying his shit,
he shit into a bag and brought it to
this lady that was in Bora.
He Shit in his bag and then handed it to
this lady and this really nice home and
he was pretending that he was this guy
who didn't understand that was his
culture.
They would shit in a bag and then hand
it to their,
their uh,
the people ran the house and it was
fucking hilarious.
God,
I wish there was a Oscar for podcasts.
Look as how we go from being on a series
positive subject to seeing Bora and the
ship positive subject.
He's the genius that is Bhorat in and
knock on green share outfit.
Amazing.
That is knocking on green.
It's a little lighter than knock on
green,
but close enough.
I don't want you to think the original
logo had that.
That guy is a character.
He is.
Did you see when he threw the ashes on a
Ryan seacrest?
Why?
Yes,
I did.
What in the heck?
He was amazing.
And Talladega nights.
That's where it is amazing.
Look at them in the middle though.
When he's all,
when he's totally serious.
That's what his wife see.
She's like,
well it's get creepy here bro.
Well I'm just saying if you see,
I look went from seeing him in a normal
suit.
I guess it would be a jacket and a nice
white shirt to being in the at like
suspend her outfit.
I would say that was,
that was normal.
And that was on the extreme side.
Yeah.
Look at him.
See now we're almost at the,
uh,
what was the ice skating movie with Jim
Farrell and uh,
what was that one?
Polian dynamite.
That was fun.
That was a fun movie.
Shareable beat you Vicki Bobi.
Sharon?
No,
that was a ricky bobby.
No Talladega nights.
French character.
Yeah,
we beat you ricky.
He did have a good,
he did.
He definitely had to get,
was it?
Um,
was it day?
Yeah.
He's his ology character.
He can't really do anymore.
I think he's doing,
what he's doing is taking cycles and
then these young kids are going to
forget they're gonna forget about
allergy and then he's going to sneak up
on them again and we're going to know
we're going to be in on it and he's just
going to figure it out.
How to get like people that just missed
the boat,
they won't wanna know what's and he'll
be able to bank a bunch of them.
He,
he can't release them.
Well he have to do is attack a bunch of
them.
Do like a several seasons worth before
he released any of it.
Maybe that's what he's been doing.
Regurge red band.
Think he saw him one night at the comedy
store hanging around.
He's like,
then it disappeared and he thought he
saw cameras and all that.
But knowing that nothing ever came of
it,
he might have,
but he got sued by a bunch of people.
Like he got sued by those young kids
that he had on like where they were
saying would they say something that was
racially inappropriate or something
along those lines?
Yeah.
That lady with the poop sued too,
I think.
Oh good.
We're there.
The dinner party,
is that Clean Jamie?
Yeah.
When he's carrying around the Poop,
you can't be doing that.
Was it someone's 15 yet?
It's super inappropriate because caveman
with some bugs.
No,
that's not butter.
It's just black.
It's just bar.
We change things around.
You know what happens man?
When I,
the butter coffee podcast,
I phlegm,
I get coffee flamethrower.
I kept it cleaner.
It's the worst.
It's super annoying.
Annoying to me and to anybody.
Yeah,
it is.
Right.
How come we got off the archery subject?
We were finally like definitely on par.
Uh,
you're a very,
you're very advanced for an archer.
I don't think that's worth not giving
credit to you for that.
Well,
I'm only advanced cause you dude.
And for cause cameron hands.
Well Cameron Hanes for introducing it to
me.
You for a tightening everything up and
taking the time to,
I mean even you have a guy who was an
Olympic coach and archery and uh,
to get someone like you for a Dork like
me who just gets into it,
you know,
it was really fascinated by it.
I feel very fortunate to be your friend
because you,
you've taught me some stuff that's
changed,
like probably taking not just years off
of my progress,
but changed it the right way.
So like it didn't matter like five years
down the road,
I might be better at doing it wrong to
the point where I kinda have my brain
calculated how to do it.
I practice it enough so I can do it
wrong and still get away with it.
You had a good detour.
Yeah.
You literally went from a super cool
hardcore bow hunter to like,
how do I become the best at shooting?
And then now you're Joe Rogan,
the hunter.
Well to me it's a,
it's like,
it's hard to say.
It's the most honest cause.
It's still,
you're still arrow and an animal,
right?
You're still using a weapon and you're
still killing it,
but it's many levels of removement from
any other kind of eating meat,
many levels of removement and this is
where it gets really fucking squirrely
with people.
It's way more respectful of the animal
than eating meat in any other way and
that that's hard for people to wrap
their heads around.
I totally understand it.
I totally understand that it's hard for
people to wrap their heads around and p
I totally understand that.
If you're annoyed,
it's me talking about it too much.
How about that?
Wow,
I get it.
All the hunters definitely appreciate
you standing up for what you're kind of
seeing the light on,
but
well,
I would be a huge hypocrite if I didn't
point it out because there's something
going on where people are deciding that
there are certain executioners they're
allowed to kill your meat and then the
rest of us are not allowed to partake.
And if you do,
then you're some sort of a bad person.
If you let an animal exists in its
natural state until one day with a ton
of practice,
I know how much you practice.
I know.
How long have you been shooting?
You've been shooting archery for?
How long now?
Right?
At 32
one year.
31 years.
Many of those years competitively.
And you still practice it every day?
That's one of the most important things.
Well,
I've
competed.
I've competed.
Uh,
let's see.
Competed.
Let's say I've competed 25 years.
Um,
but the reason,
the only reason I competed was because I
wanted to make sure that when I was
hunting,
I was proficient as a hunter.
That's the only reason I started
competing was I wanted to make sure
that,
you know,
I remember going out the first time as a
hunter and finally having an opportunity
and then missing.
And I think I was a lot like you when
you got into it and you realize this is
something I'm really into.
You're like,
okay,
how do I actually get good at it?
I don't want to go out.
I don't want to go out and shoot
something.
And you know,
up the butthole or whatever it is,
right.
You're like,
I want to go,
I want to make,
I want to literally make a good shot.
I want this to be something that I'm
cool with and then I want to be able to
enjoy the benefits of it.
So that's why I started competing was
actually went to my first archery
tournament,
um,
based on the side,
a sign on the road.
I was driving down the road and I saw a
sign that said,
and for those of you who are listening,
um,
there was actually a cool little like
documentary that hoyt did for me called
I am defiant.
Yeah.
You were part of that whole post.
Probably the,
if somebody programs.
Yeah.
If someone's listening and they kind of
want to see my background and know how
kind of Joe and I came together that um,
the,
I am defiant video from hoyt is really
good.
You can find it on youtube.
But um,
you know,
I was supposed to play college football
and I was a bow hunter,
but I wasn't very good at it.
I didn't have anyone that really taught
me how to do it.
I was self taught,
my dad introduced me to it and my uncle
mainly.
And then I ended up going to this
archery tournament based on a sign on
the side of the road,
said archery tournament.
And when I went there,
I lost all my arrows before I'd finished
because I was so bad at shooting and
being a,
you know,
a person that was really wanting to play
college football.
That was like the first time I really
felt defeat and just the competitive
drive in me is like,
I have to do this right.
So the people that won that tournament,
all of them had these shirts on that had
the name of the shop.
So the next day I was in that shop and I
was just watching these people shooting
and started asking questions and I
realized that myself taught or family
taught way was just a way to get in.
But then it just got so much more
diverse and I think that's what
happened,
you know,
for you.
Cam was like your uncle,
he literally brought,
he brought you into,
he brought you into archery,
right?
And then,
um,
once you're
uncle cam nylon,
that'd be awesome.
You need,
you need to do a,
we need to do a,
he's like my crazy uncle that runs ultra
marathons.
We need to do a,
um,
a photoshop thing with Cam and an Uncle
Sam outfit.
But Uncle Cam,
uh,
he brought you into archery and then
once you were there,
you realize,
wait a minute,
when I go out,
this is a huge responsibility.
So how do I,
how do I go out and if I'm going to put
this responsibility in my hands,
how do I make sure I'm 100% knowing I'm
doing it
the right way?
Let me just point out that this is not
because I didn't have confidence that
Cam,
it's more that I am a junkie for
exploring options.
And I get,
when I get into something,
I start trying to find all the different
variations.
I tried to find out who's doing what,
what are the target shooters do and what
did this go like?
This,
it's undeniable that Cameron Hanes,
like one of the greatest bull hunters in
the history of human beings.
Right?
So just becoming friends with him is
amazing.
And I should probably just follow his
lead.
Right.
But my thought is I know that that works
and I know that works for him,
but I know that there's certain things
that work for me that don't work for my
friends.
Like I have friends that won't do yoga.
I fucking Love Yoga.
I have friends,
I have friends who won't float.
I fucking love floating.
I love it.
You know,
you don't have to the loaded yet
tonight.
You got to try it.
Go try it.
Oh look it up.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's the greatest thing of all time.
[inaudible] it up next to like a four or
five things.
Yeah.
What I'm saying,
I'll look it up
and be knocking on like pull a bunch of
strings to make it happen.
I'm gonna call a guy door to the
basement when to call a guy.
You can put me in this dark room and
open it up after my plane leaves is one
of the greatest things of all time.
Once you do it you realize like why am I
not doing this all the time?
It lengthens your body out.
Everything just sort of relaxes and sort
of um,
gives,
you know like there's like tight areas
and your back besides like the mental
properties,
the things that you can do mentally that
one of the big things it does is all the
magnesium gets inside your muscles and
it's like a massive epsom salt bath.
So everything just gets loose and is
certainly a smell in there.
Yeah.
What salt?
It's just a salt smell.
You don't want to do dude,
I,
I hold onto my hips like this when I'm
in it and I can make my back pop like a
lat spread like I can.
Yeah.
But I'm like pushing down on my hips and
I could feel,
I could feel my back pop and looking at
the dude.
It's strong.
V Big Man.
I bet you lift weights.
I bet you do.
I sling some K bs.
You got to get in there man.
And um,
do you do any sort of decompression
stuff?
Do you ever look,
hang by your ankles or hang like
actually do a lot of hangs.
Those are great.
Two things or one thing I want to,
I didn't say today,
but when you we were doing,
I did that stock because you were tagged
out.
So I did that stock had a really good
stock.
If it wasn't a sow,
it was game over like that.
You got within how many feet?
I Dunno,
it was probably eight yards,
nine yards.
When I stopped and came back and then
came back in,
the animal stayed in its place.
So you were so quiet at 235 pounds.
You got to crawl through the grass.
I got video of it.
It's kind of creepy.
He told me I was like a Predator is a
fucking big predator.
It's creepy to watch the holding your
bow and Arrow creeping up on these
animals moving so slow.
But you know what?
I give credit to that for yoga.
Oh yeah,
that helps.
Did you notice that?
Did you ever,
did you put that together?
When I was going,
well I know you've been doing it and I
know you like it,
but I just thought you,
you're a big athletic guy.
I know you played football and I know
you run a lot.
You mountain bike a lot.
Yeah,
but that's the difference of your body.
Slow movements is way different than
power.
Yeah,
right.
For sure.
So I think I really credit yoga.
My wife started doing it and she kept
saying like,
you really need to try it.
And then when I heard you talking about
it,
I tried it and then now I'm to the point
where I do it and it's,
I mean I wish all guys,
but I think it's if archers could only
do one thing,
I would say find a really good yoga
place.
If they could do two things,
I would say yoga and kettle bells and
then if they could do three things,
I would say yoga,
kettlebells and God,
that'd be tough.
I'd say weights,
but then heart rate is relative to take
cardio
too.
But I just feel like your ability to
maintain posture is really relative to
yoga.
So like when I was stocking one thing
that you did that when I was filming and
I stayed back just for sound,
I stayed back and let you do your thing.
I've wished I was the guide at that
point where I could tell you because you
were behind the guide,
so he didn't really know what you're
doing,
but I was really wishing I could say
like your bow instead of being sideways
where it's easiest to carry,
it needs to be at the ready and just
when you're,
everything you did need to be,
maybe it's your martial arts background,
but you were,
you know when we'll get on this subject,
but you were going this way and this way
and this way,
so you're like your angle of attack.
Even though it was in a straight line,
it was still horizontal.
Whereas did you notice my angle attack
was always at a posture to where I could
move 28 inches and I was where I needed
to be draw,
right?
Yeah.
I definitely once,
once we talked about that afterwards,
I got that.
That made sense.
I did feel weird though about holding up
the bowl while this dude is front of me.
I did feel weird about that.
I was like,
I gotta have this point into the side.
I didn't feel right.
Even though it takes a whole step to
pull it back and draw,
it just didn't feel right to like have a
bow pointed towards some dude's back.
I know it's stupid.
No,
it's not.
It is sort of,
but it's not because if someone tripped
or something went wrong,
but I do think that um,
doing yoga has made my ability to move
slower,
better as well.
I think it,
what I was talking about earlier about
lifting weights and stuff,
it's nothing wrong with lifting weights,
but I think there's an overlooked thing
that we were talking about in the car.
It's being able to control your body and
that's what yoga does almost better than
anything else.
The balance that you get in the,
the ability to move your body and all
these different ways.
It just doesn't seem as sexy as like
squats or dead lifts.
Fuck,
we do dead lifts if feels like you're
getting some shit done.
You know,
I love dead lifts.
Don't get me wrong.
I feel like I'm getting callous.
Has done like these babies are from
dental bell dead lifts dead well
kettlebells.
I feel like I get more pressure on my
forearms from channel that a lot of
hanks to right.
That'll,
that'll definitely give you some houses.
That's,
I mean for a lot of people,
I think a very neglective movement and I
heard this on your podcast and I called
you and I'm like,
dude,
I do those.
It's just hanging,
literally grabbing a bar and fully
extending yourself to where your bay,
your body,
a long gates,
your joints.
I think it just brings so much like
lubrication to your joints and the
longer I hang,
do you,
do you hear yourself adjust?
Do you hear like little things?
Click hopping in my lower back too.
Yeah.
Especially if I can get a place longer.
We have a hard time getting way you
could feet could
dangle.
See,
that's the thing about being short.
If you get a good one,
you're freaking dangle.
You can do at the playground.
I have to go to a freaking tough mudder
to get my feet.
Do you go to a playground?
Some of these playgrounds,
that goddamn brutal kids keep breaking
their arm and they've got damn monkey
bars.
But yeah man,
I,
my daughter broke her arm and a monkey
bars.
One of her friends at school broke her
arm and a monkey bars.
I broke my arm on monkey bars.
Monkeys buys or fucking dangerous man.
Well I want these kids bell from metal
bars.
See when you're falling you're only
phone a few inches.
It's different from everybody else.
Maybe that's why I like my size.
If you fall off the monkey bars,
a fucking long drop.
It's a lot of action.
But when you can hang from something,
this is all from my friend Steve Maxwell
told me all about this.
He says,
we get podcasts phenomenal and he's
like,
it allows your,
your arms to like sort of loosen up
those joints.
And give them some mobility and
flexibility and it makes a big
difference.
Man,
I made a huge difference.
Me.
Soon as I started doing it,
it really changed when my shoulder
started feeling,
well,
we both have had shoulder problems,
right?
Yeah.
And just located mine.
I didn't even know.
I did see I was the same.
I dislocated in mine and it froze.
And then when I,
when I was like too,
too ignorant to know that it was a
frozen shoulder and I forced myself to
like talk myself into the fact that it
wasn't a rotator,
then it went back in and that noise,
it's pretty,
I mean,
you know the noise,
the noise,
man,
that was really shocked when I heard
that ours didn't clunk in.
I told him,
remember it when I get sad,
by the way,
the injury,
like the way the inside tissue looked,
he goes,
it looks like your shoulder was
disconnected just located.
So I said,
are you sure?
He's like,
yeah,
I'm pretty sure it's like the way you
have these little bits floating around
in there.
He's like,
usually that happens when a shoulder
gets dislocated.
Oh
Yeah,
mine wasn't good.
I remember Sharon looking at me and she
goes,
was that a good pop or a bad up?
And I said it was,
it wasn't the good one.
Definitely wasn't seat short faced bears
don't have these kind of weak ass bitch
body problems.
What those short faced bears,
they don't have these bitch body
problems.
Problems pull trees out of the roots and
beat people desperately have knee
problems,
lower back problems.
They get talk that would make them so
much creepier.
No uhler fuck you telling me you
wouldn't have a short face bear here if
you knew he wasn't like a mean one.
See you say that.
But if he's a short face bear,
he's a mean one.
That's like saying no,
no,
no.
That's rude.
You can't just come up with a new way
him.
He's a friendly shark.
Sharks I've encountered,
I've encountered a lot of bears and
bears have personalities.
I'm sure some bears have very short
tempers and their,
you know,
their total like snap spazzes like Jim
Miller just instantly snaps on you and
freaks out and then some are really calm
like polar bear.
Yeah.
Like a polar bear and then game,
they whole new.
He's your buddy.
They cuddle you.
They do all that stuff.
No,
because the only murder the seals when
you're not looking,
they only want you to watch watch.
I have to defeat they jack the scene
going bobby,
bobby the polar back,
beat
his murder in some seal choking down and
getting back to surface and pretending
to be your friend.
Just some P is everyone listening?
Census.
Sarcasm.
Like I don't want to throw a Jim Miller
under the bus.
No,
Jim Miller is awesome.
What do you mean it sarcasm.
Oh,
like they were just checking.
Right.
Cause he's,
it's hard to know.
They don't know your relationship with
Mr. Miller.
He's an awesome dude,
is as awesome as it gets guys.
They're all good.
Yeah.
And you,
uh,
you took him on a pig hunt recently?
Yep.
Jim Miller.
Who,
if most people who listen to this
podcast to follow the UFC know Jim,
he's a one of the top 10.
I think he's top 10 lightweight in the
world.
Just lost a really close fight to
dustin.
Pour.
Yay.
God.
I,
so that was as close as it gets.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Awesome fight.
But if he's not taught townies,
certainly top 15 in my eyes,
at least he is.
I'm saying top somebody.
Well that's hard to argue honestly.
Cause he's,
he's lost to some of the best guys.
And there's still Tony Ferguson.
There's still habib number.
Good madoff.
They,
those are the top two guys.
They have to fight for the title.
But did he lose with he lost with a
close fight?
Yeah,
no,
it's true.
There's no doubt about it.
No,
he's an awesome fighter.
We talked about that.
That was the first fight that I ever
watched and I,
I'm,
you know,
I remember the first UFC fights,
but that was the first time I ever
watched one where I felt I had,
I had vestments in someone and you know,
I knew Jim was fighting for,
was that two eight cause I saw him fight
at 200 and he stood on the cage and
then,
cause I was sitting right behind you.
Any like,
you know,
he said let's go.
Yeah.
So how cool was that?
It was very cool.
Is that you're sitting there and the guy
just wins a fight in.
The first thing he wants to do is go
over and point to say,
200 let's go out and that was so
awesome.
It was so bored when both those guys
have done that.
I was,
I was so happy.
I was like,
it's so cool and I've got both of them.
Both of them are coming to Iowa in the
fine for the Turkey belt.
One month they're fighting for the
Turkey belt and I'm in there too.
I'm going to bitch slap those suckers.
Turkey.
The Turkey belt is a thing that John has
every year.
Our bitch knock on loud in UFC.
I agree.
They should be.
If I don't see,
they don't know what's coming.
Wait until this bitch supposed to have a
closed hand,
but you can slap some on the side of the
head though.
Dude.
I'm going to put all 15 inches.
This bitch slap right across both of
them.
I think it's probably better to punch
someone.
Otherwise people would just be bitch
slap and people.
They used to be an organization called
pancreas and they used to only bitch
slap for real.
Yeah.
Pancreas was not allowed to strike with
a closed fist except to the body.
But uh,
they could head kick.
It was crazy.
They fucked up and they made the rules
that perfectly
fit boss route and style.
Bas rutten,
who was UFC heavyweight champion too,
who beat till she [inaudible] back in
the day,
Bas rutten was a just a murderer.
His kickboxing was just terrifying to
these guys and he came in out of
nowhere.
It was knocking dudes out with bitch
slaps you never heard.
A boss is a friend of mine.
Boss ruin is amazing.
He's amazing.
He was the first like really technical
animal striker to fight in the UFC.
Actually Maury Smith was a really super
solid technical striker.
Good Bitch.
Slap or dude,
look at that bitch.
Look at that mid.
If it had to be done,
I'm 65 bring your mid up against mine.
Yeah,
they,
they're the wrongs.
If you got,
if the camera will.
Seriously,
they're the same size,
but they're the wrong size for my body.
My mother smoked when I was a child.
I don't know,
Dude.
I think you had some silver back in your
background.
Well,
if I had a guest,
someone fucked him monkey when they
shouldn't have,
you know some of those like,
can I still fuck monkeys?
No,
you shouldn't.
You can,
but don't feel like you should know
better.
Stop fucking monkeys,
bobby.
You're like,
come on one more monkey mind.
So some northeast Jew or a zoo,
sorry,
g
seven Dorothy Zoo.
Someone's going to take that out of
context.
Yeah.
That'll be a,
that'll be a front page of the news.
I would assume if people came from lower
primates,
right?
If human beings came from lower
primates,
which they think we did,
like,
it couldn't have been a totally even
process.
You know,
there's,
there's people like I have always
wondered like,
what is,
what is the ultimate form of the human
being?
If we came from some sort of a hominid,
some sort of a Australia pick his monkey
thing and became what we are now,
right?
What the hell are we going to be 2
million years from now,
5 million years from now?
Like what is it?
Do you think so?
Yeah.
Hell yeah.
Why would it be like that guy?
That guy's a douche bag to the hines.
He's invisible.
Exactly what he's cheating.
He's not,
he can't even sneak around.
Dude.
He takes this bottom part off and he
doesn't have any genitals.
That's true.
He gave it to me just for hunting.
Yup.
And he'll do an alien.
He'll do what's right.
He was doing a shorts and Agar hunting
aliens.
It's not a lot like people hunting
crocodiles.
Wait,
see,
isn't it,
would antis have a problem with Predator
came down when you say antis you mean
anti hunters?
I speak the language.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Let's go champ.
A lot of people don't know.
Yeah.
Um,
I think they would say open season on
the Predator.
Makes Sense.
So why that's the Salem is fish hogs,
first of all,
because it's not we,
it's not from here.
It's not from around here.
At a certain point in time,
people get hog is not from America,
not from America,
but at least it's from the planet earth.
Yeah,
we can.
We can.
It's got create shipments.
You're pushing the border while you were
pushing the border with Noah in the Ark,
right?
Yeah.
There was supposed to die in the flood
and put them all over the world.
Is that ice going further?
Jamie chimes in fine,
but in these in,
Oh man,
that's hilarious.
Seriously though I d I know you cut
yourself short on archery.
I definitely don't.
I enjoy it.
Enjoy the process.
It's fun.
But seriously,
joy learning,
social media people,
they're actually jealous of the fact
that you got cam to bring you to hunting
for sure.
And then now you're getting like,
well,
cause I don't really work on people's
bows.
I've worked on friends bows and you get
a lot of bows.
Yeah.
You said you hooked my bows up,
dude.
I appreciate it.
It,
you know,
there's like people who are like most be
nice cam,
take some elk hunting.
John's works on his bows.
Listen folks,
not fair.
Life's not fair to let them tell you,
man,
dude,
they're fucking lying.
Do you give,
say it's Finna get to do Jiu Jitsu with
Bravo.
You get to do so machado stuff.
What else do you,
who do you learn pool from?
Um,
well I've,
I've had a bunch of friends there were
really good at pool,
but one of the big ones,
my friend Max eberly,
he thinks the world's flat,
Wonderful Guy.
A Max [inaudible].
He's a fantastic pool player.
That was,
this is going to be at a Max.
I'm like,
there's fundamentals
cool that that mirror,
they don't mirror the consequences or
the actions of archery,
but they mirror the mindset and the
proper form and the proper,
the proper delivery with the minimal
amount of like variables,
like muscle movement or torquing of the
hand or all those things that is very
similar in pool.
Like when you get really good at pool,
and I'm definitely not really good,
but when you get to a certain level and
people that are really good,
they get this,
well,
it's like I used to play eight to 10
hours a day.
Like all the time.
You're saying you weren't good.
I was never like world class.
I was never like even national class.
I was like always a b player.
Like at my very best I was a beat.
This is totally being honest.
And then there was a players and there
was pros,
right?
I was never an a player,
but I learned how to get,
I got better and better.
And if I played for many,
many hours in a row,
I'd start getting loose and I could run
some racks sometimes,
but it was never a real good player.
But one of the things that I realized is
that when I played my best,
I was barely holding the cue.
It's barely holding it.
It's like I knew that the less control I
had of it,
the more I could let the queue do the
work.
And I had it tuned into my mind and it
was all about being in the correct
stance,
making sure that you come through the
ball perfectly.
Meaning that like the delivery,
the stroke,
where it's just this natural smooth
motion.
And if you do that you,
you get to this state,
they called dead punch or you get into
dead stroke,
like some guys call it dead punched,
some guys called dead stroke,
but when you're in dead stroke you can't
mess.
You see the ball different.
You see angles on the ball.
You see when,
when you know that when you release the
cue,
when you let that cue go forward,
that tip is going to smoothly striked
the cue ball and it's going to collide
perfectly with the ball that you are
aiming at is going to go to the center
of the pocket and it's going to roll the
perfect position and you might only be
able to do that like a game or two in a
row.
For me,
I never got into it where it stuck with
me for like hours and hours,
but I had a friend,
my friend Johnny B,
who I grew up with,
grew up in pool with who was a hustler.
I met him when he was a pool hustler and
he was this really fucking smart dude
who was good at,
he was just,
he could play chess.
He could do numbers in his head like you
could throw 500 times a thousand minus
six divided by three he'd go forward 65
definitely before 65 but he could do
that like it was,
it was weird.
He had a weird math brain that I don't
understand at all.
And he would get to the asperger's or
no,
it was just a brilliant guy.
Just his just,
his mind was different.
It's just a different mind.
One of the first people I've ever met
who his mind was just so different than
mine.
Like the way he thought about things and
the way his brain would,
the RPM considered different?
No,
no.
He was normal street smart,
very street smart and fun and funny
character,
but it's really a lot of different
traits.
This guy who would get,
he would get loose when we play pool and
for hours he would be in this dead
stroke where it was just insane.
Like you,
you couldn't,
you people would gather around and watch
him play.
They would gather around and was like,
you were watching an art form.
Like he had this way of getting out.
He had his way of moving a ball around
the table that was so smooth and
elegant.
If you did it yourself and you realize
how difficult it is to watch,
it's a different perspective.
But pool is is a beautiful art form that
only the people who know how to do it
can appreciate.
And I think it's the same with archery.
And one of the things about archery is
if you watch a guy like yourself or any
of the top target archers and you see
those guys on the TV and the Olympics
and their aim at those spots and they
release that Arrow and it goes to the
center at home,
you're watching it going,
Yay,
he got another bulls eye.
Or again,
I misses and you're like,
what the hell?
You're watching these guys do 10 in a
row,
12 in a row.
But when you do it,
you realize like,
oh,
this is a mirror into the mind.
This is one of many disciplines that are
Amir into the mind.
You,
you get to peer into an area of yourself
like internally,
and you get to figure out through these
motions,
like where your mind's at and how to
discipline this,
this sort of process of learning and
getting better.
And archery is a weird one,
man.
Where to seems like it should be so
simple.
Like what's so hard?
You put your arm out,
you aim,
you let the Arrow go.
That's it,
right?
Yeah.
No.
That's why this same thing.
They're shooting at the same spot for
the same distance over and over and over
and over again,
and it's insanely difficult and you have
to be a robot.
It's insanely difficult.
You have to re replicate your movements
and smoothness and your breathing is
important and your concentration.
It's a fascinating discipline,
man.
It's fascinating.
And if I never bow
hunted again for the rest of my life,
I would 100% still practice our tree.
100% it's a form of meditation.
It is.
It's a spectacular one,
man,
because it's so rewarding.
Like when were practicing,
we were at camp practicing out to 90
yards.
That was as much fun as hunting.
Oh yeah,
I love it.
Yup.
It's the the most fun way.
Was I in that,
what was your Pool Guy's name?
Johnny B.
Yeah,
and Johnny B zone.
You're definitely in a Johnny B zone,
but you're always in a johnny b zone
with archery.
It's very annoying.
It's like he just,
we,
we had a pie plate out at 90 yards.
This mother fucker like pop right in the
middle of the pie plate.
I'm like,
how the fuck can even see that far?
I can't even see what that thing is.
I don't know.
You hit it.
You're lying.
I hit it a few times,
but I miss it a bunch of times too.
But,
but my point is that like you're,
you're the,
because you're so technical,
you're amazingly consistent.
And there's one I was saying earlier,
like even though you've been doing this
for so long,
you still practice every day.
That's the crazy part about it.
That it is this discipline.
It's a fascinating discipline,
you know,
and then start to,
you start to really crave that.
Like you and I were talking with Steve
About.
He kept saying,
I want to get into working out,
but I don't,
you know,
and there's all these buts,
but you and I were saying,
dude,
we're to the point where that is part of
our lifestyle.
Yeah,
that's part of our daily routine.
If I don't go to the gym,
it's to me if I don't somehow test my
body each day,
whether,
well one,
it's with archery,
I test my body practicing and then I
also test my body.
Whether I'm doing,
whether I do yoga day or kettle bells or
whether I lift or whether I bike.
Either way it's a task,
but that's,
that's part of my routine.
No different than,
you know,
our series lifting.
I have to brush my teeth every day life.
I always want to see Harry every morning
before he goes to school,
right?
You want to see your wife and you want
to talk to your wife and you know,
in bed or whatever.
You always want to have that connection
time for you to sleep.
That's part of a routine.
And once you get into that routine,
your body craves it.
It doesn't want to miss that part.
Well,
it's also,
you can regulate through those.
And one of the things that I've noticed
is when I've taken days off of a
exercise and I've done it many times and
I did it pretty recently because I was
kind of feeling sick.
I was like just kind of feeling kind of
crappy and my kids had colds and I was
like,
man,
I might be coming down with something.
So I said,
I'm just going to just chill out.
I'm going to,
I'm just going to bathroom.
Go ahead by the war.
I'd never be that guy who don't worry
about it,
man.
We can make it happen.
Bladders.
It's right there.
Go through that door and golden.
Um,
what was I just talking about?
Thank you colds.
So what I did
was I took like maybe four or five days
off work and at,
which is super unusual for me.
I just said I feel just a little tired
and I know this is going around.
I feel it trying to creep in.
So I took extra care,
my health,
I took extra care to drink like a lot of
green juices and eat a lot of probiotics
and I said,
let me just recognize what this thing is
and catch it.
Did some breathing exercises so I never
got sick.
But what I did do is I took all that
time away from working out and I started
feeling not so happy.
Like I don't want to say I was depressed
because I definitely wasn't,
but I felt a difference between my
happiness level.
Then what my happiness level is when,
um,
I'm blowing out all the stress when I'm
blowing out all the stress.
Then I look at life as this.
I know it's not going to last forever,
but it is awesome right now.
Like,
shouldn't I just smile and enjoy this
awesome thing right now?
Yes,
of course I should.
And so I embrace the awesome things
about this awesome life and try to take
them all in as much as I can and just
enjoy the moment.
But when I exercise,
that comes almost natural.
It just feels like the thing to think of
the thing,
the way to do,
especially if I exercise hard,
if I can get through a brutal workout,
the sky seems brighter,
the air seems clean,
air people seem happier.
I feel like I can change the way I
interface with the world around me.
It's,
it's not just as simple as you know,
you work out because it's good for you,
you work out it cause it's,
it's good for life.
And I just think it's so easy to fall
prey to our natural instincts to want to
be comfortable all the time.
And I think the more you do that,
the mall more you fall prey to the
natural instinct of wanting to be
comfortable at the time you deny the
observable Yin and Yang to the universe
that the universe requires these moments
of discomfort,
like hard workout sessions and in order
for you to feel good.
And I also think your body has these
natural reward systems that have been
implanted in us through millions and
millions of years of being whatever the
fuck we were when we were,
you know,
millions of years ago.
I think people have these things
embedded in their head and they,
there's a certain requirement of,
of panic.
There's a certain requirement of
exercise,
there's a certain requirement of
protecting your environment,
surrounding,
recognizing the dangers around you,
like how much of that is left.
Well if you grow up in the inner city
and it really gang infested crime ridden
neighborhood,
it's way higher ramped up than it is.
If you know you're a kid in beverly
hills and your parents are super rich
and their parents were super rich and
you don't understand like what it's like
to be in a dangerous place.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I mean people were very strange.
John Jug,
John Dudley and we're very strange.
Don Judge John,
I'm talking very well,
a buddy of mine,
um,
dusty filling up in BC one time.
Like what a great name.
Yeah,
dusty Philly in the fillings are
awesome.
I love those guys.
But it sounds like a
character on a Stephen King Book.
He's awesome.
Found a spaceship with Jeremy.
I'm gonna give a shout out to both of
them.
Screw it,
Jeremy.
No,
he was also awesome.
What a great name for a Stephen King.
Both of them are always my camera people
when I'm up in BC hunting.
And the problem with having a fulltime
camera person,
it would be a lot like you trust in
Jamie with this podcast.
If he was also potentially like a
personality of Jackass.
Oh Wow.
You would think that
I gave them my
camera and they had it because they
wanted to make sure it was always
charged.
The card was always empty.
So when I get home and I load all my
footage,
I have this
now,
all these recoveries by my animals or my
hunts with them posing as don gently.
It's like the guy that you trust.
Like when we trusted Steve,
we said,
hey dude,
get a picture of us,
you know,
glass and over here and then all it is
is this big freaking beard taking
selfies.
He took every reason he was pretending
to take our picture.
He took selfies and then we got it.
What the fuck man?
He starts laughing and then he took the
pictures.
He was a funny dude.
A really funny dude.
He was.
He was real cool and really good at his
job.
He knew that place like the back of his
hand gesture,
guys,
pleasure to hang out with.
He was made an awesome [inaudible].
He did good.
Beautiful as well.
Beautiful.
But um,
no,
when I walked in you were talking about
kind of the importance of the Yin and
Yang.
It's a lot like that.
I think with any sport that's an
individual sport,
especially when it's a finesse sport,
you have to,
a lot of times you have to lose control
and especially lose the ego in order to
excel in the outcome.
So like a lot of the ways that I coach,
I take away your ability to control and
then slowly bring it back to you
and what people don't understand what
you're saying.
Let me just explain to people that have
no idea what archery is.
If you're still here,
I'm just kidding.
Millions.
But what I'm saying is that when you are
learn our true,
one of the things that happens to some
people,
I should say a lot of people as you get
something called target panic,
and that means like what you try to do
is you try to have a hole on it.
Here,
let me explain it to people I think
because they don't know you.
You get scared of it.
No,
it's scared of the word good.
Okay.
But it's a good subject.
Go ahead.
Gets mice.
Okay,
I'll be right here.
I'll explain to people.
Then you'd come back and fill in the
blanks.
Um,
it,
people panic the other side.
There you go.
Um,
they panic and they can't keep the spot
look where they're supposed to aim on
the target.
Like sometimes they're low,
sometimes they're to the left and they
circle it in there and then pull the
trigger and they freak out.
And it's weird because it becomes like
the psychological,
um,
sort of a trap that they fall into.
And it's really common with target
archers.
And I think something has to do with the
monotony of continuing to stare.
At a spot and sometimes being dead on it
and sometimes not and eventually it
builds up in your head.
We're trying to figure out how do I time
this thing where I hit that trigger
perfectly?
Well,
someone figured out a long time ago that
if you use a release that doesn't let
you know when the arrows going to go
off,
it's a surprise shot.
Then all those tricks don't get worked
into your system.
All the tricks your brain plays on,
you don't get worked into the system and
John has an amazing method of what in
what we're saying,
taking away control.
So that's what it means.
You what you do by taking what you
controls,
you develop this tension release that
you're just pulling through the shot so
you can't anticipate when it's go on
going off because the muscles are not
nearly as sensitive as the ones that are
on your finger and anything that's used
to manipulating things.
Yup.
You,
you literally,
you minimize your focus on literally a
process.
So you occupy your conscious mind.
This is probably equivalent to most
sports,
but your conscious mind,
if you occupy it with a fight or flight
syndrome or a fight or flight reaction,
a lot of times when people experience
performance anxiety,
they're triggering,
triggering a fight or flight experience.
Right?
So I mean,
even with fighters,
even if they know how to move and they
know how to punch and they have a game
plan of how they should attacked a
counter.
Mcgregor once say you get fricking
cracked hard with that left hand,
you go,
your,
your conscious mind goes from your
trainer saying slip and moves,
slipping,
move,
keep moving.
And all of a sudden you get hit with
this thing that,
that occupies your conscious mind to a
thought of fight or flight.
We'll now it starts thinking about what
you're doing and then all sudden you go
into attack mode,
right?
And then your game plans out the window.
So it's the same thing with archery.
You want to,
you want to occupy your conscious mind
with the process instead of a result.
So,
you know,
that's a good way of putting it.
Yeah.
So we're,
we're focusing a hundred percent 100%
and I've worked on you with this,
I've worked on Aubrey with this on a
process and the,
if you only focus on the process then if
you couldn't,
if that ice shield was out there,
the ice wall and you could never see the
result,
I would guarantee you that the result in
the end would be,
you know,
if there was someone on the other side
saying Joe Rogan is an unbelievable
archer because you never knew the result
you are on this side of the Ice Wall
saying I'm only caring about the
process.
So I take away all the tools of the
which you've
essentially those tools are what you
came up with on your own when you said,
I want to get into archery and I bring
you into a process.
And then once you understand that
process and I a hundred percent trust
that you know the process then all
sudden give you a tool to have ultimate
control the result which is like what
you know for a year I worked with you
and then in the end you came back to the
NOC to it,
right?
Yeah.
That released that you use,
well the just the release method of not
having any control over when it goes off
like that made my archery alone without
the corrections and the form that you
did for me.
That made my archery alone more
effective and more satisfying because
like as we talked about like archery's
is strange discipline and when someone
points out the pictures to you it's sort
of,
it sort of illuminates the process in
this weird way that makes the process
more exciting.
Like everything you do,
if you enjoy doing something when you
first start doing it,
once you get better at it,
you're going to enjoy it even more.
That's a big thing with Jujitsu Jitsu
Jitsu.
It's,
it's a huge part of learning and growing
with Jujitsu is trying it out,
getting good at it,
and then
call up Jeremiah for me while we're
podcast.
We'll do,
we'll,
we'll set that up afterwards.
The Guy in 10th Planet De Moines 10th
Planet.
I'm going,
you should do it.
It'd be fun.
I want to do it.
And you,
you're going to meet some nice people.
They're not going to hurt you.
I don't want my archery shoulders ripped
out of socket.
If as long as you learn how to tap out,
super important.
I can tell it to learn how to do that
loud to me.
I do stuff on big,
but I'm willing to submit.
You gotta do it.
Whoa.
I'll do it.
Sounded super good.
Ooh,
someone's a bear.
Not a bear.
It's a bear at the top.
How's that been?
The like the nomenclature in the gay
community.
The bears a big furry one,
but it doesn't necessarily mean he's
dominant.
Right?
Where did we go?
You don't know what bears are?
No,
he never heard about living in Iowa,
bro.
Shooting the bows and arrows hide in the
woods.
There's a category of,
uh,
gay men called bears weight there.
Uh,
usually like bald,
very hairy.
Get back to the NOC to your idea.
I mean,
I'm not,
I'm not saying that there's a problem
with it.
I'm just saying I'm venturing to the
area.
That's not my expertise.
Well,
the area of my expertise is bears.
That's uh,
I've been,
uh,
when was it?
What'd you call a bear?
Ologist
there's a name for him,
right?
What does the term,
the term was?
It persists.
Is that the term for bears?
The,
the technical,
you would know way more than me.
I think it's,
it's an Ursus.
The most stuff I learned is from my son
right now.
Oh,
really?
He's 18.
And he comes home with some crazy,
crazy stuff.
He wants to be a veterinarian,
right?
Yes.
Yeah.
So that's good.
And even study some shit,
dude.
We're going to,
we're going to Hawaii.
Do you know about this?
The White Sand
in Hawaii?
You know what it's from?
I would assume it's from seashells to
look up what?
The white sand of Hawaii look up what
it's from.
This is going to trip you out.
Oh my God.
I'm tripped out already.
So pumped and it's educating.
Joe Wrote,
Oh,
it sits bones.
Bones.
What does it is in the salt and sea,
right?
Right.
That's fish bones.
Yeah,
the salt and say what now?
The salt and size,
not really a soon as the primary cause
of the white sands of Hawaii.
What is it?
Why are we playing games?
It's don't hide.
It's parrot fish.
Shit.
Really?
We're literally going to be walking
around on deficoat.
Why white sand beaches are made from
parrot fish poop.
Oh my God,
I'm so pumped that I taught Joe Rogan
and some crazy is insane.
That possible.
That's in that.
Oh my God.
It just shits like crazy.
The thing shit sand.
Oh my God,
it shit.
Sand does that thing eat like a reef.
What is it eating?
You know?
It was at a hunting camp.
It what does it eat?
The sponges and oysters also produce
Pacific Ocean stand sand,
but no animal.
This as proficient as the parent fish
stomachs.
Damn.
Meals past strikes bypass like a gastric
bypass or someone who has lower cost
producing as much as 840 pounds of sand
per year.
Q.
Imagine if your poor little asshole had
a process yours.
You're a big giant guy.
Have your poor little asshole ahead of
over 840 pounds of sand per well.
Let's break that down.
How many pounds is that a day?
Because 365 days in a year.
And it's what is,
it's more than double that,
right?
Yeah.
What would a 40 pounds so that is more
than two pounds of sand through your
asshole every day for a year.
That's insanity.
Now that you're a fish.
So think of that.
It's not even a person.
It's a fish.
A little fish.
It's pumping out more than two pounds of
sand through its tiny little asshole
every day.
That's insane.
There's never been a thing like this.
All right,
well
come on man.
How old are you?
How would the lighting dead?
Coral.
How would that,
how would that translate to a 200 pound
man?
Can we do the math on that?
Oh,
it'd be insane.
Run some numbers.
How big or one of these fish?
How big is a parrot fish?
It looks small.
It doesn't look that big.
Look cool though.
His Lips.
Yeah.
No,
that's not Nimo,
right?
That's a clown.
She had a whole new appreciation.
Mimo.
Oh,
sorry.
gangster.
Yeah.
You most have make it sand with this
little fairy tale.
A little double stilts skin nemos a boy,
right?
It sounds like a boy.
That's kind of weird.
Ambiguous.
It's Pat Chapman.
Then sucker out.
What a trip that is from another planet.
Check out the beak on that sucker.
It's got a chicken beak,
dude.
If there was a pond on the moon,
the Rhino Horn,
that would be the number one article in
the history of the world.
Check if that thing out was in a pond.
Look at the blue.
What?
The cammo.
That sucker.
That's a whole new like UAA baron.
Cammo.
That's insane,
dude.
All you see is that eyeball floating
through the water.
You're like,
is that a set of milk dud?
No,
it's a parrot fit.
Look at that guy.
He's got a green eye,
he blended and even better.
Doesn't that thing look like something
that belongs in a different era?
Yes.
Everything in the sea.
It's 10 times cooler than on earth.
Do you agree with that?
Ah,
it's hard.
You get cool with an eagles.
What?
You get cooler than an eagle?
Look at that thing and has a rhino bump.
That's the rhino in the zoo that get its
horn cut off with like some cool lips,
but dinky eyeball.
Here's what's cooler,
buddy.
Eagles.
First of all,
Eagles live in my world.
Respect.
I'm all about the people that breed,
that animals that breathe air next,
all those water breathing.
Motherfuckers can kiss my ass.
Okay,
I'm on team air breathers.
Second of all,
what's gangster about the Eagle is the
eagle can manipulate three d space where
everybody else is trapped on the ground.
The Eagle has got a whole different way
of operating.
They can fly over and dive bomb on Shit.
They catch fish with their hands.
They just swooped down in the river and
Jack Fish with their hands and carry
them off.
They're there.
They're existing in our world.
But not by our rules.
That's why they're the official mascot
of United States of America.
Well,
let me,
let me tell you this.
Please do.
So I'm just educating you on what I was
fish pool baffled.
Yup.
So get this.
Don't blow my mind again,
John.
Dudley.
Dude,
if you live with the 17 year old,
which you will soon enough,
you're going look at that under water
iguana.
Oh my God.
I was just affects the code.
Those suckers,
they go 50 feet under water.
You gotta watch the new planet Earth
two.
That's where the first one.
I watched him get that thing.
That is insane looking.
That looks like a monster.
This is literally,
is this Pacific Rim two.
Do you remember that little baby?
Uh,
what?
the little baby like Guana running and
all the snakes are chasing it.
That was from planet earth.
That's one of those getting hatched on
the beach and it's running to the rest
of it.
Like group real.
It was real clumsy.
Iguana that we're looking at.
It's crazy.
These things look like monsters.
It just small.
That's why Godzilla was such a dope
movie.
Dude.
You're going to learn so much cool
stuff.
When your kids are 17 type in this type
in um,
coral
ejaculations on full moons.
You do you know about this?
Thankfully No.
How dare you wait till you find out what
happens on a full moon in eight o'clock.
I don't want to know.
He probably don't.
I'm scared now.
It's like a bad hot tub at the Holiday
Inn Express.
Isn't it funny that people are so silly?
Like we know there's sharks in the water
but surfing is so much fun.
Would take our chance.
Yeah,
absolutely.
That's with everything in life.
Dance over the head.
There's risk.
That's a big one though.
Short little ride.
Did you find anything?
National Geographic had a special on
corals.
I think it's like eight 8:00 PM on a
full moon.
Yeah.
All I think coral like literally drops
it like it's hot.
Really?
Yup.
And how does it get the rest of the
coral pregnant?
Cause corals not like a,
it's not a plant.
No,
I think it's,
is it an asexual?
Sure.
I'm seeing this stuff called the corals
spawn.
Yup.
There it is.
Here's a little,
and after we looked at this,
we've got to check out all the new shit
about the Great Barrier Reef.
Whoa.
That is crazy.
Look at that creature.
This is coral.
This coral orgasms.
That's what that is right there.
Pretty low.
They go in those little holes.
It's like that game at the carnival,
right?
Isn't it?
Like the calm comes out in little balls
and it goes in these round holes.
Jamie type in,
um,
moonlight triggers mass coral romance.
Wow.
Yup.
This is stuff you learn from when you go
to your seven o'clock breakfast with
your teenager and he's a straight a
student.
Wow.
And he's like,
Dad,
did you know?
Yeah.
The sunlight triggers mass coral.
I look how they put romance in quotes.
It's equally correct till now how the
primitive animals,
which lack brains or I synchronize.
So their animals.
Whoa.
Wouldn't they be,
would that night be considered a plant?
Okay.
This are people that say plants don't
have feelings.
I don't know.
I mean seriously,
they're saying it's an animal.
Boom.
What constitutes that?
I don't understand.
I don't know.
Let's look that up in a second,
but synchronize the mass spawning was a
mystery.
Um,
okay.
In today's issue of the journal Science,
researchers reveal that they have
isolated in ancient gene in the corals
DNA that can detect moonlight by
exposing the corals to different colors
and intensities of light.
The team found the gene known as C R Y
two was most active in Appro,
uh,
crapo.
Mm.
Uh,
crobe Po Ra,
a cro,
Paul Hra.
That's a corals during a full moon.
Wow.
Yeah.
It encodes a type of protein known as
crypto chrome,
which appears to trigger the corals
reproductive cycle.
It's a wearable.
It's literally at 8:00 PM on a full
moon.
Certain coral,
literally it's a werewolf.
We'll do dallas.
Getting back to what we were talking
about earlier,
about bucks,
about how strange they are that they
only breed once a year for most of the
year.
There's no breeding and then something
happens and they all turn into fuck.
Werewolf's crazy.
Now this bouncing a girl was through as
humans.
There'd be a big sign up at 10th Plan
Jujitsu.
Oh,
it'd be giant.
Cause people would be like,
wait a minute,
you're telling me once a year I got to
be gangster and by the way,
everyone would take steroids.
Okay.
If it was steroids,
grew,
you antlers everyone and antlers,
how did no one would be,
no one accepts natural antlers.
They would be like,
okay,
all bets are off.
We're stabbing each other with weapons
to grow out of our heads.
I can't just play by the rules,
you know?
Because when,
when antlers clash and deer and elk,
they kill each other all the time.
Right.
You stumbled upon heck yeah,
all the time.
Right.
All of the thought of the time.
It's every year program.
Every year in Iowa on the different
farms that I hunt,
I find either two bucks that are locked
together and dead or a buck that's dead
kind of based on a puncture room.
Right.
They fight.
Remember that we were actually,
when we were at that to hone,
we talked about some of the elk that
people took last year and the manager
said that one of the bowls they took was
because of the fact he had broke his
horn at one time and he grew that spear
out of the front and they said he kept
killing other elk because he,
when he would fight,
he literally had this broad sword where
everything else had this like steel
mace,
right?
Yeah.
Everything else would,
they would co connect almost like people
like locking their hands to write and a
game of mercy and one guy had a fricking
wolverines,
like a terminator two Frickin sword on
his arm.
He had,
it was ridiculous and they're like,
okay,
we gotta drop t2.
It's just a fascinating thing that these
animals develop weapons every year and
they collide with each other and smash
each other in the head and then they go
back to normal.
Like nothing ever happened.
It's a lot like guys,
we talked about this.
Yeah,
but it's not,
if we could only do it once a year,
where would you go?
If the quickening happened once a year
and every once a year everybody started
getting crazy and horny and dude's
running red lights and he's breaking
into people's houses.
I'd go to,
I'd go to my house and I locked the door
down.
It's not good enough.
You've gotta be,
you gotta be able to stay awake because
if deere,
we'll let people,
people know how to open doors.
I have to stay awake,
stay awake,
you gotta I could stay away.
You got to put like metal all around the
house.
You gotta have all your friends over and
everybody has guns.
You gotta you gotta keep an eye out for
the outside they would call it the
fucking people just couldn't help like
for for three or four days out of every
year,
everybody just loses their mind
completely.
That would be the equivalent to what
happens to animals when they were in the
Rut.
Like we'd be talking about finding that
more dough and all those men were just
jumping her.
What's at the purge that you wouldn't be
similar.
But I mean the quickening is not that.
It is a quickening just made him not the
quick a's.
A weird one.
That's one of the ones that are,
it's the idea that art bill always
brought up on that show.
Do you ever listen to the art bell radio
show?
He's the best.
He's the best art bell was like this.
A late night
radio hosts a legendary late night radio
hosts that always entertained all these
people.
He had these people on the show that
were psychics or they were big foot
experts.
Are they,
were they worked at [inaudible]
experience 2015.
Yeah,
in many ways.
In many ways.
I owe it to art bell and I did his show
and uh,
when I did his show was a huge honor for
me.
Like,
and I,
people are mad.
So it was pretty,
they were said that I,
I,
it was some Ufo researchers got pissed
off at me because I was saying that most
of what you see,
but it's,
I'm still intrigued by the idea of alien
life,
but I think I'm done with that in that
what we're dealing with is a lot of
people that are full shit and they're
making things up and that's what's going
on and there's a lot of like these,
these,
these images that people doctor up.
Then it gets proven their doctor,
but they get into the mindset.
They get into the Zeitgeists of these
people that believe in Ufo isn't,
it becomes something that you wrote and
I was there.
I used to be 100% in on an area 51 on
Roswell and Roswell.
Yeah,
totally in.
Yes.
I thought for sure.
Rabbit hole.
Hanger 18 in Ohio kept a Ufo that
crashed and Roswell's.
Yeah,
I was convinced in the Roswell.
Will you ever convinced to that,
Jamie?
I've heard of things.
Yeah.
Right,
pat?
Yeah,
that's what they say.
Wow.
Yeah.
Hangar 18 was in a movie that has
terrible Ufo movie back in the say about
aliens,
but the idea was that who was the
president during 1947 was it truman?
I think it was truman.
He flew to New Mexico and then flew back
with the wreckage and they flew it in
two separate planes.
The wreckage of this aircraft history
came from another?
No,
most likely not,
but that's probably what a lot of people
thought it was.
What they think it was most likely
either crashed weather balloon or maybe
some sort of a Russian Zeppelin spy
something or another.
They don't know what it was.
Yeah,
well weather balloon,
not as that plan.
Like one of those,
they would use these weather balloons to
spy on people and there was another
thing they did.
This was a really fascinating episode of
Radio Lab.
I wish I could remember it,
but they the name of it
rather,
but they sent bombs in Japan,
sent bombs over to North America flying
the jet stream and balloons and they
land.
It was,
the idea was to send bombs without any
soldiers across the ocean riding the jet
stream and they would land in America
and fuck people up and some of them
didn't go off and people would find them
like when they would go digging around
for shit,
maybe some of the metal detector
logical,
right.
It's happened.
People have died.
They blew up.
If you let a healing,
which I did and like fourth grade I led
a helium balloon up with a letter on it.
Oh Jesus.
And it said like whoever gets is,
I'm from Johnsburg elementary school or
whatever,
you know,
please write me back.
And then people would get these
postcards and said,
all your balloon landed in Ohio or
you're bleeding landon in Michigan.
So it's really not that far off
mathematically.
Right.
If you knew how long healing would last
in a balloon versus the current of the
air staying,
guess it right.
Though they didn't have the proper
ability to guess it right back then.
But they did get some of them through
and some of them did detonate,
but a bunch of them went missing.
And people did find some of them.
But the,
the,
the episode is fascinating cause you
just think of the,
the crazy mindset of people,
like one of the first things they
figured out when they figured out that
there's wind that travels in a very
predictable current around the world.
Okay,
how do we fly something up there and
drop it on the bullet?
Is it predictable though?
It is because it's a competitive
advantage in the game of war.
You know,
and the war in a lot of ways becomes a
game buddy.
Rest of us has got the advantage.
Yeah.
In that way.
But obviously not,
um,
weapons military was 75% first.
Yeah.
Right.
They could get to us quicker with the
jet stream,
but nobody's using the jet stream
anymore.
I mean they had a brief window to
kicking on the Internet.
Now will they use,
if they're going to use missiles,
they're those like that's what scares
me.
Like everybody's worried about Russia.
What about North Korea?
Don't they have missiles now?
Isn't that Kinda Kinda crazy?
Didn't he just killed his half brother
show glee,
intimate one missile?
They were really excited when one got
off the ground.
Dude,
if North Korea was made out of diamonds
that right,
weren't they really excited when one
went up?
I think they fired one recently and it
went towards Japan and they were really
super pumps.
So it's 2017 and they got one to Japan.
There's just letting bitches know he's,
he's ready.
He's ready to launch.
But could you imagine if that place has
made out of diamonds,
how quick would be in there and fucking
everybody up?
They'd be like,
yeah man,
we gotta protect the world you don't
need.
And these oil,
yeah,
oil's good,
but diamonds are better.
If you get a whole country filled with
diamonds,
you'd have to get those two beers people
on it about broadheads good broadhead.
It's not worth nearly as much as
diamonds.
North Korea missile explodes within
seconds of launch.
US says that's what they would say.
Yeah.
Say Yeah,
that bitch just blew up.
Motherfucker.
Probably like everyone at an outdoor
theater watching it and they probably
are required to watch it.
I wouldn't have imagined that.
That would be fake.
I bet that's what the one in that
picture was that a Chrysler,
they get what they can get.
It's probably a North Korea creation.
Chrysler Caravan.
Who makes that?
That's probably a North Korea for
action.
Wait,
is that a rabbit or I can't even
recognize it.
That is to make their own cars,
right?
Wait a minute.
What?
Korean missile launcher,
that's not even legit.
Are you sure?
Yeah.
What website is this?
NPR.
Okay.
I bet you he's right.
That's a Scud.
You think so?
Yeah.
It says people.
What does it say?
People with news footage of her missile
launch outside the main railway station
and,
well,
maybe this is just what they're shitty
design looks like.
North Korea missile test failed just
moments after launch Wednesday according
to us and South Korea.
Maybe they reproduced a Scud md bucking.
That just been an old picture they used
to use for my wife's bunking.
Why would npr do that?
Cause it just happened today.
They didn't have an updated picture of
Oh,
but don't be faking guys like Don John.
Dudley will fucking call you out.
John.
John,
Don Schlein this on my tongue.
Tongue's not arrived day today.
The Rye brain name,
you do this.
It's a good combination.
It's Alfred who didn't watch,
we should keep this up because it's
almost four o'clock and uh,
we got to get some cooking to do and
before we some not we.
Yeah,
we got some knock to hog.
The roast up.
Yeah.
This is going to be interesting for
those of you watching who didn't know
Alpha brain from on it,
the peach flavor specifically mixed in
one bottle of water with a Yeti Rambler,
10 ounce.
And today we're on the angel's envy
Angel's envy whiskey.
Who brought this?
It's been here.
It's been here a while,
but this is a very presumptuous name.
Angel's envy.
That's the point of it can fly you.
Fuck.
They're like eagles,
but they're like super tight with God.
Okay.
They're not envious of your whiskey
lady.
Better imagine people saying that like
you're,
you're my whiskey.
So cool.
People wished they weren't even angels
looking to join my whiskey.
What kind of whiskey and you selling,
sir?
Yeah,
we're behind Angel's envy.
For those of you listening,
thank you so much.
But we do have,
we have the two of us have,
we want to enjoy something together.
It's called some wild pork roast and
angel's envy.
I want you to know I'm just fucking
around.
I don't really,
it's just a name.
It's a beautiful name.
It's delicious whiskey.
Are you worried about them being mad at
you?
I just want to be nice to people,
man.
So I'm trying to do in this life,
through this life,
be as nice as many people as possible.
Thank you.
About the looking up the cool stuff.
James and awesome.
Jamie is on top of the needle.
Jamie.
So bad.
Gosh you don't say
a Jamie.
There's one jamie,
you will do that.
Someone to perform similar functions.
Yeah,
but Jamie say people say I want a friend
like a Joe Rogan and I'm like,
he called me out on twitter.
Yeah.
Cause I shoot a bow lane.
It's all right man.
Everybody gets drunk.
I'm down with,
I'll say
is how
his,
he got bombed and then called me out on
twitter.
No,
no,
no.
It's been very important to me,
man.
It helped me a lot tremendously.
And I think it's cool that you put all
that stuff online.
So recovery just telling you,
okay,
podcasting is about conversation,
man.
It's about just talk and occasionally
you want to figure out who wins a fight.
Short face bear or one of them bears in
West Hollywood.
I'm thankful you listen to my podcast
for sure do I do and I think,
um,
like people that are really interested
in archery,
like there's this rapper going to try it
levels.
You can get down the rabbit hole,
please try it.
Try to find a good shop near you and
theirs because of John Lott,
other people.
There's just some great resources online
so you can find out a lot about the art
of archery Zen.
The book of archery is what you
recommended.
That book to me.
Thought it was really interesting your
take on it too.
Like it seems like a guy who's not
totally there,
but he's talking about it and he's like,
he gets it.
But you didn't think it was written by
an elite archer.
Nope.
See that so fast.
And it's funny,
as I read that book,
because I listened to my first gre
Podcast,
I read that book,
um,
in Mexico,
which actually youth member I laughed
like the same day you were coming in.
Totally.
It was,
it was crazy.
And I read that book and then I told you
what my thoughts were on it.
And certain parts of it are really cool
because there's certain parts of it that
I can relate to for sure,
but it's just like anything with yoga or
meditation or anything else,
there's,
it's all state of the mind,
right.
So it's also in a language that's
extremely complex and I don't think it's
the same.
I don't think their interpretations of
what we call things,
I don't think it matches up with the way
they feel about things.
So when you translate something from
Japanese,
especially Japanese from I think it was
the 14 hundreds yep.
When Miyamoto Musashi wrote the Big Book
of five rings,
you translate from that to today.
I think you miss,
you're missing a lot.
You're also missing the reality of their
life,
the feudal life and death.
I could agree with that reality of sword
fights and that there's an intensity to
their existence.
That I think is very,
very difficult for us to quantify today
and that book is it's,
you almost have to sit down and think
for a long time before you open that
book.
You've got to put yourself and don't
just read the words,
read the words and imagine that this is
an interpretation of someone's words in
Japanese who was maybe the greatest guy
that ever lived at fucking people up
with swords,
but he was really into calligraphy and
he's really into art and poetry and he
was really into meditation.
He was a ta and he was really in a mind
games.
He was a totally different kind of a of
of figure because he seemed to me in a
lot like when you're trying to like talk
about mastering archery or trying to
master Jujitsu,
there's things that are vehicles for you
to try to develop your potential and
some vehicles are more extreme than
others.
Like our friend Cam Haynes selects to
run ultra marathons and then he wrote a
run the big foot 205 pound man,
205 a mile marathon,
which is insane.
I mean those people that pick those
paths like that,
what they're in some sort of strange
way,
people that pick these like super
extreme pass or kind of redefining what
people are capable of,
you know,
he and engaging with the most extreme
aspects of life there.
The,
and then they turned life up to 10 and
then regular life becomes almost an
insufferable,
it's really fascinating.
Well,
like with me archery,
it'd be 10 which most people can't even
relate to that,
right?
Yeah.
Most people have a hard time finding
anything that they really,
really sync up with.
But what I think is that when you see a
guy like,
you know,
like a,
a super athlete like mighty mouse,
when you see a fully dedicated super
athlete,
when you see,
I mean there's a lot of consequences to
it.
Mighty mouse does extreme consequences,
but then you go one more level.
And that sword fighting,
I mean these,
these fucking people that live in feudal
Japan,
the Rowan's,
they would,
he killed 60 something people with
swords and one on one.
You looking at each other and just
fucking chopping people up.
Yeah.
Like mayweather's is may win a 39 and
[inaudible] 49 and now 49 and 49 and now
imagine them being that guy.
Yeah.
It's another level,
right?
49 no in boxing and it's not up to a
judge that's up to us.
Sword.
Oh yeah,
totally different.
Well,
his style would never work.
So I mean Greg or work a little bit
there because you're so vulnerable.
Cracker or may weather.
Oh,
we changed subjects.
Um,
mayweather is a way better boxer.
There's just no doubt about it.
He's one of the greatest boxer,
if not the greatest boxer that's ever
lived.
And even though he's smaller,
you're talking about a completely
different level of skill,
a completely different level of
understanding of the subtle nuances of
boxing.
But that said,
conor mcgregor is not incompetent.
He's very dangerous.
Floyd mayweather is a way better boxer,
but conor mcgregor is dangerous as fuck
and he has a really deceptive ability to
move in and move out.
He can cover distance very quickly and
he can do so a weird way.
He
can do so in a way or he might stun you.
It might stay on you and you might catch
you early and he hits really fucking
hard.
But if floyd can figure him out and
start using his jab and using his
movement.
See,
floyd has traditionally had problems
with south paws,
but he's never lost one.
He's still,
and he's talking about professional
boxers.
You also have the bigger glove factor.
Con is going to be wearing bigger gloves
then he's ever fought in the UFC before
the UFC gloves or four ounces.
Most likely if I was floyd,
I would insist on 10 ounce gloves.
I would want this motherfucker to have a
lot of padding on his knuckles.
I don't know.
I don't know if they're going to do
that.
I think the,
I think everything below one that sucker
out.
Oh,
you're so silly.
Wait,
what is the weight that they were above
one 60 I think it's 10 ounces above one
60 and eight ounces below.
I've been where you spin to counter
fights with you.
He's incredible and all I can say is
when connor hits a guy,
their face instantly shows the fact that
they don't know that it was really that.
Is that fair to say?
They don't know that it was really that
meaning that he hit so hard,
like he stunned them.
I think what he's saying,
I know I'm going to get hit with that
left,
but when they actually get hit with the
you a person's expression reveals what
they actually felt and I think people
feel like it's harder than what they did
in training.
Well,
you know that people.
True.
Yeah,
for sure.
Well,
you know that people could run faster
than people,
right?
You know there's certain people that
have special gifts,
they have special gifts of athletic
movement,
and some people have in extraordinary
ways,
gifts have power.
When it comes to striking and it doesn't
make any sense,
but I've seen it from people where you
see what you think is hard and then you
see someone else and you'd go,
what in the fuck?
Yeah.
Like there's a video of George Foreman
hitting the heavy bag.
Right.
And George Foreman was,
I don't know if he had fought Ali yet.
I don't know when this,
I think this was before the Joe Frazier
fight.
My might be wrong about that,
but pull up George Foreman hitting the
bag cause it's a really recent cliff
that's been going around.
Some people have sent it to me on
twitter for sure.
Heavy heavy bags.
It was just,
Oh yeah,
you could see it.
You see the bag,
you see him it.
But you got to hear it.
Listen to the sound of this when he's,
and he's winding up,
no doubt about it.
But what he's not trying to work on for
him,
he's just work on power.
Look at us,
literally been picked up his feet.
You gotta you gotta see when they show
him really digging in c he's like
swinging more prodigious site.
It seems to me that of all the people
I've seen hitting a heavy bag and
cooling Sonny Liston,
no one ever hit it the way.
And he would just wail these full power
punches.
And when he would fight people,
like when he fought Joe Frazier,
he hit him with punches that you could
tell had an endeavor been
hit like that before.
Right?
Like George Foreman moving his feet.
Look at this.
Those last two are insane.
So his ability to single power punch was
so extraordinary that almost no one
could stand in front of them.
And we stay in that sort of a barrage.
That's a freak athlete.
And those come along and when those come
along,
if they're smart too,
and then they're,
they're really good at learning the
sport to a lot of people were trash
talk.
And that's where conor mcgregor is.
He's a freak athlete in the sense that
he has this,
there's a guy named for Rasa,
hobby hobbies,
one of the best trainers in mma,
George Saint Pierre,
his trainer,
he calls it the touch of death.
That's the best way to describe it.
He just,
he'll best time I saw it.
I saw when he hits people with that
left,
it doesn't look like you watched Brock
Lesnar windup and crack someone,
which I saw.
And then you see conor,
which you don't even realize the punch
came in and then their face is like
swelling up instantly.
That's like what we just saw with
foreman.
Yeah,
well it's extraordinary for sure.
The difference between that and forming
is obviously foreman has big heavyweight
gloves on and he's punching a bag that a
guy's holding and there's a lot of
padding between that dude in the back.
It'd be interesting to see someone,
when you see someone stand in front of
form and informal,
we hit them.
He was like one of the most
extraordinary power punchers in history.
They didn't,
it was like,
have you ever been close to an airport
and you see a big like seven 57 coming
in and you're like,
is that thing going to fall?
He's too big to be a mom,
right?
Yeah,
but that's what foremens when he would
swing,
you would think,
okay,
that's not doing much.
And then you would just see people rankl
yeah,
well he was at Swedish guy,
but not big by today's standards.
I think foreman was probably only like
two 20 something back in the day.
See if you could pull up George Foreman
versus Joe Frazier.
He got way big as he got older.
When he came back,
when he was like super heavy,
like he wasn't well over 300 pounds and
he made his comeback.
I think he was like 36 years old.
Nobody took it seriously.
Then you start blasting people and then
after a while people were like,
wait,
what?
He just knocked out George Clooney
possible for connor to look at that.
He was to 17 when he fought.
Joe Frazier was lighter to me,
but look up the video.
It's lighter than me,
right?
Yeah.
That's a UFC light heavyweight before
they cut weight.
Like John Jones probably weighs more
than that,
which is kinda crazy.
But watch when he started connecting,
it's a quick fight,
man.
It's a quick fight.
George Foreman was fucking terrifying.
Just go like deep into it and you could
watch the pummeling he gave him on the
ropes is horrendous.
Yeah.
When he hit him,
he just shook.
I remember this fight and he pushed him
off and boom,
look at,
look at that.
That's like him hitting the heavy bag.
And the guy's just like,
what the Hell Dude?
Look how fucking powerful foreman was
back then.
And look at that like that opera caught
when frazier collapses.
Dude,
play that again.
This is insane.
He was just so murderers.
You saw my God.
It actually shook then before he got sat
map.
Boom.
But this last uppercut here is dome.
I mean,
come on.
It's incredible.
Foreman was scary.
His hips.
He's so scary.
Yeah.
Joe Frazier took a horrible shot.
Now today they'd probably stop the
fight,
I'd imagine.
Cause he looked super wobbling and look
at that.
You would miss out like right there.
They stopped the fight.
Not will.
It was a quick knockout man.
That lady got up that look fake.
Almost.
No,
it didn't look fake at all.
No Man.
You don't know what you're talking
about.
He's wobbly cause he's central nervous
system shutoffs wildly because of what
he took about 30 seconds ago.
Yeah.
Not because of what he just took right
then.
Oh,
that,
but that was part of,
that was why I said they would have
stopped the thing on the top.
Yeah.
But it didn't look fake.
It didn't look fake.
It was a guy who just,
I don't say it's fake,
but I'm just saying we kept the,
because they kept the match going.
It didn't take much to finish it.
Right.
Boom.
Dude.
He was terrified.
He was,
I don't want it any more of these,
like cinderblocks dropped on my face.
What was incredible?
Is it f you know,
frazier had gone
15 rounds.
Muhammad Ali.
Right.
And then you see that and you're like,
wow,
this is a scariest guy ever.
And that's why they thought that George
Foreman was going to kill Muhammad Ali.
It was so depressing to people.
I remember when I was a kid,
my parents loved Muhammad Ali.
It's like one of those things that
people,
the generation loved him because he
didn't fight in the Vietnam War and he
did.
He wanted to like protest against these
senseless wars and so they stripped him
of his title for three years.
Like he was a different guy,
like he represented so much to people
back then in some,
some sort of a weird way.
So when he fought George Foreman,
people were so terrified that he was
going to get beat up that hunters
Thompson didn't watch the fight.
He was sent to Africa to watch the
fight.
He had tickets to be ringside at the
fucking fight to report for it,
for the rolling stone.
You know what he did?
He just fucked around and and wore a
Nixon mask and climbing the swimming
pool and hung out all day and drank.
He just did.
He's like,
fuck this.
I'm not going to go see that.
He was convinced that Muhammad Ali was
going to get killed and he loved Lamanzi
legend die.
He didn't want to say it and he missed
the greatest come from behind upset
victory.
Right.
Arguably the history,
the heavyweight division even bigger
than when he knocked out Sonny Liston,
the wind,
the title.
That was a big upset because everybody
thought that Sonny Liston was just this
fucking killer and this young kid talked
a lot of shit.
But once sunny got ahold of him,
he'd be fucked.
But nope.
Nope.
He his face honor.
So you don't know.
You don't know because we'd never seen
conor box.
What would you say?
Maybe there's a way better boxer,
but the consequences of connor hitting
you should be greater.
And I say should be because I think
he's,
uh,
he's certainly a stronger punch or than
mayweather.
Right,
right.
But I would agree he has boxing gloves
on and know how much more of,
of an effect is his punch going to have
when he has a giant padded glove.
You know,
I would,
I would assume there's going to be a
diminishing for sure out of the class.
Yes,
for sure it was.
But how much also the ability to block
punches,
it's far easier to block punches when
you have big gloves on because when you
have big gloves on,
if you watch a guy like floyd,
he catches his shield.
Yes,
he catches punches and he's,
or even deflection.
And it's magical.
It moving away with them.
Like he gets hit,
it gets hit and he's hopping wait on his
feet.
So you're catching the end of shots.
I don't know conner,
as much as,
I mean I'm not a UFC buff,
but all I can say is I've seen conor
mcgregor shots go in when I didn't even
know they were going there.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
But again,
a four ounce glove is lighter than an
eight ounce clubs.
The punches are not going to be as fast.
If it's a 10 ounce glove,
it's definitely slower than it.
That's a good separation of boxing
versus UFC then?
Well,
there's also a good separation of the
fact that there's many more openings
when you have smaller gloves.
We have smaller gloves.
It's much more difficult to cover your
face.
So connor has extraordinary power.
He's got extraordinary movement and he's
bigger.
He's a far bigger guy.
I mean,
he's a big frame guy and he's strong.
And Young Floyd Mayweather is 40 years
old.
He's arguably the greatest boxer of all
time.
I mean,
he's a phenomenal craftsmen.
Like the way he understands the art of
hitting and not being hit is
extraordinary because he's not running
away from guys don't stand rice.
Right?
Yeah.
He'll stand right in front of you and be
untouchable.
He's only been rocked like legitimately
rocked maybe twice or three times and
his whole career,
he,
since he's an outstanding,
if you took those away,
what if you took,
when he got rocked versus when Diaz
choked him out,
do you think?
What do you do about it?
We're talking about two different
fighters.
Well,
what do you think conor mcgregor got
choked out by new ideas or if he takes
away where they got rocked?
No,
I'm talking to when conor got hit pretty
hard when it came back.
Right.
Versus when nate just choked him out.
If you eliminate nate choking them out.
Right.
Do you think he's got the heart to,
to really stand through a full fight
with mayweather?
Well,
he certainly does because he went
through a full fight with the,
um,
with Nate Diaz.
He won the rematch and a five round war.
Yeah.
Which was good.
It's you.
You can never guess like anybody who
guesses what a guy has like as far as
heart and determination,
it's foolish.
He'll show you with his actions where
she'll show you with her actions.
You can't guess.
So whenever people,
guests,
they start saying,
oh,
he'll never be able to survive a tough
fight or he doesn't have the guts.
Then you,
you mistake like your understanding of
what you see in front of you for what's
going to happen.
And that's what a lot of people did with
Muhammad Ali versus George Foreman.
So a lot of people doing a lot of
fights.
One of the things that makes this fight
intriguing is we've never seen floyd box
a guy like conor mcgregor and we've
definitely never seen conor mcgregor
box,
especially at a level that the UFC,
excuse me,
that floyd
mayweather is at.
So him coming from being a two division
UFC champion will help his confidence.
He'll be scary.
And one of the things that he said that
that's a psychological thing that no one
could ever say to floyd before.
He said,
listen,
he goes,
the only reason why this thing is fair
is because we're playing by books and
rules.
If it was a fight,
I would fucking kill him.
And the way you said it was like a
hundred percent accurate,
100% accurate,
and he,
but he said in saying that something no
one's ever been able to say to floyd,
I will fuck you up.
Like in Floyd's going to know that at
any moment,
if connor wanted to just slide a little
bag and start kicking his face or
kicking his legs out from under him,
he wouldn't know what the fuck to do.
Do you think he knows how to block a
wheel kick?
He's going to get kicked in the back of
the fucking head and say,
connor,
pop the referee and then just we'll get
there.
You'd have to,
you know,
he would have to get close enough to him
to do that and it wouldn't be as easy as
it seems,
but the distance between punching and
kicking is pretty substantial.
Right?
Connor closes that distance in a really
fast and really spectacular way.
He comes at you with Shit Front kicks to
the body and you're trying to figure out
where he's coming and what he's coming
with.
Very unpredictable.
So I think in a boxing match,
if you have $100 and you have to bet on
someone,
so the odds are going to most certainly
favor floyd mayweather because it's a
boxing match.
It was a fight.
It would be 100 million to one that
conor mcgregor would fuck him up.
I mean,
I'm not exaggerating it,
putting my course,
I'm exaggerating.
No one would give you those kind of
odds,
but it would definitely be something
ridiculous if it was a fight.
Don't you think?
Like what would it,
wouldn't it be?
It was a fight an mma how?
Don't know if I had to be 100 million,
if I hadn't of seen conor live,
if I hadn't of seen counter live and how
people's faces looked when they got
tagged by him the first time.
Right.
I would say I would put money on me.
Whether based on what you just told
everyone with 10 bucks to do,
but the fact that I've seen people get
cracked by him and I've seen their face
swell.
Oh yeah.
By him I,
I don't know.
I think he's going to freaking rock him.
Okay.
A lot of people in America do,
and that's why we're going to sell it on
paper view.
John Dudley pay per view coming soon.
Apparently they're trying to do it out
of here.
We got hog because before I got a
flight,
they're trying to do it in September,
so that's what I heard on the Internet.
So I know as much as you people know.
I just think if it does happen elk
season,
yeah,
it'd be a problem problem.
It's better as a problem.
That's problem.
Thanks sir.
We got to get down here this weekend.
Yeah,
we got to cook up.
So Jamie,
you're also pig.
Probably James.
Beard and hat.
We'll be back tomorrow.
The robb Wolf.
See you later.
Okay.